ou que nous avons créée il ya quelques
années avec angie des grands débats dont
l'idée était d'organiser des événements
sur le site d' angie ouvert aux
personnes extérieures et sur des thèmes
proposés par l'école de paris là la
crise de l'aco vide nous a amenés à
innover alors la façon dont le débat
s'organisera nous aurons une première un
premier étant qui est le débat
proprement dit ou jean marc jancovici et
didier tholot débattront ou j'animerai
ce débat ce débat devrait durer autour
d'une heure et ensuite dans la deuxième
partie les participants pourront
intervenir ont posé les questions nous
avons 230 participants là pour l'instant
de donc ce qui était convenu c'est dans
un premier temps chacun des orateurs
présente qu'ils sont et d'où ils parlent
suivi d'une précision sur leur vision de
ce qu'est la transition et ceux qui dans
cette position dépendent de nous et
dépend pas de nous il faudrait préciser
comment chacun voit les risques à ne pas
le faire peut-être vous pouvez commencer
avec déjà pas vous présenter pour a
précisé de vous parler va commencer par
jean-marc très bien alors j'ai deux
casquettes principal de casquettes axe à
fort accent soir ça pour faire plaisir
aux mines mais bon en cas de location du
temps donc mes deux casquettes principal
c'est que je suis associé une entreprise
s'appelle carbone 4 qui aujourd'hui est
présente à la fois dans le domaine du
conseil aux entreprises essentiellement
soit les collectivités locales sur les
questions de thé carmona sur farm sur
les questions plus exactement vingt pas
que l'activité sur le climat est impacts
du climat pour l'activité et qui est
également présent dans la fourniture de
données au monde financier
sur le même sujet
ma deuxième casquette c'est que je suis
président et fondateur d'une association
qui s'appelle dauchy project et qui
ambitionne très modestement d'essayer de
constituer le lobby de toutes les
entreprises qui très égoïstement en
condé carbone l'économie parce que ça va
être bon pour leurs affaires je cherche
très ouvertement à une collection
d'intérêts égoïstes
après avoir rendu la vie pour lui il est
compris que c'était comme ça que ça à
reims est en démocratie
la troisième casquette qui est la mienne
c'est que je suis très modestement
enseignants unique paristech
je fais un cours pour les élèves de
première année qui est un panorama large
sur la question énergétique et enfin ma
quatrième casquette c'est que je suis
membre d'une des commissions de macron
créé tous les six mois et donc celle à
laquelle j'appartiens s'appelle le haut
conseil pour le climat qui se situe deux
crans avant la convention citoyenne et
la résurgence du commissariat au plan
un autre entrant avait aussi fait une
commission d'économistes d'idéaux l'eau
bonjour je suis idéologie je suis
directeur général adjoint d'énergie je
suis dans ma carrière j'ai été dans la
fonction publique j'ai fini ma carrière
publique comme directeur de cabinet du
ministre délégué à l'énergie sur le
gouvernement bérégovoy puis ensuite j'ai
fait toute ma carrière à gaz de france
puis gdf suez puis angie je suis
actuellement en charge de deux
portefeuilles bien distincts au sein de
la direction générale benji qui sont
d'une part les infrastructures gaz en
france qui correspondent à mon passé
très gazier dans cette entreprise
et deuxièmement tout le business du
groupe en asie pacifique
ce qui me donne une vision un peu
stéréoscopique de ce qui se passe dans
le monde de l'énergie est aujourd'hui
presque évidemment vite la france est
vue de singapour où il ma deuxième base
le monde de l'énergie n'a pas exactement
le même aspect est d'avoir ces deux
points de vue permet quelques fois de
relativiser un peu ce que nous voyons de
l'un ou de l'autre des deux poignets
voilà donc maintenant quelle est pour
vous la transition
et qu'est ce qui dans cette transition
dépend ne dépend pas de nous on va
commencer par jean marc jancovici
alors là la transition pour moi on
pourrait l'expliquer je pourrait la
résumer comme un exercice qui doit
passer d'un immense et de casse bonbons
à un aimant c'est positif
l'énoncé de casse bonbon c'est d'arriver
à faire tenir une humanité de quelques
milliards d'individus sans que ça
dégénère en boucherie sur une planète ce
qui fait désespérément 13 8 kilomètres
de diamètre et pas plus et donc qui n'a
qu'une capacité d'éditer à assurer les
prélèvements et des rejets qui sont
constitutifs de tout être vivant et de
toute organisation structurée structures
et organisations dissipatifs d'énergie
et donc pour pouvoir s'organiser croître
parfois simplement rester en l'état
elle doit cacher dans l'environnement et
l'accueil dans l'environnement
et quand ont franchi les seuils dans
leur sens ou dans l'autre
il suffit d'attendre et on se met à
avoir les problèmes qu'on commence
aujourd'hui déjà avoir de façon non
négligeable donc la transition c'est
d'arriver à préserver les cons peu
préservé dans les acquis qui nous ont
été amenés par l'augmentation de l'usagé
de l'énergie tout en essayant de ne pas
étouffés sous les inconvénients a mené
par cette même évolution et qui
s'exprime en général de manière décalée
alors en termes très concret le sujet
sur lequel le moi je suis qui est la
question climat et donc la crise en
carbone consiste à m'occuper d'eux
décarbonés l'économie mais sachant que
la transition peut également ne se
limite pas à ça il faut aussi éviter de
faire mourir et dans l'océan
dans cette affaire ce qui ne dépend pas
de nous ces lois de la physique
donc la loi de conservation de l'énergie
il dépend pas de nous les équations de
maxwell ne dépendent pas de nous et la
deuxième chose qui ne dépend pas de nous
le sait les ordres de grandeur c'est à
dire qu' il ya quelque chose que
j'essaie d'enseigner à nos étudiants aux
mille dès la première minute du premier
cours c'est de leur expliquer que pour
faire le tri entre une bonne et une
mauvaise idée est énorme atomique
s'appelle mark ii iii qui est très très
peu utilisé dans la décision publique
est en débat public alors qu'en général
ça permettrait très vite de savoir
qu'est-ce qui est une chimère
qu'est ce qui relève du greenwashing
qu'est ce qui relève de là j'ai envie de
dire l'envi qu'on arts de caen c'est que
le problème est réglé relève de la
méthode coué
et qu'est ce qui a vraiment une chance
de réussir le gros c'est ça qui est ça
le métier l'activité dans laquelle je
suis et tu es tu n'es qu'une activité
dit fondamentalement est une activité de
casse bonbons parce que ça consiste à
supprimer des degrés de liberté par
rapport à ce qu'on pensait être
l'aisance avec laquelle on pouvait ce
pouvoir à l'avenir est quand même le
maître du positif et du projet dans tout
ça ce qui est évidemment il ya une
partie d'exercice de haute voltige dans
cette histoire parce qu'il faut
transformer une contraintes en
opportunités
voilà donc c'est ça en gros alors qu'est
ce qu'on risque elle pas la faire c'est
la deuxième partie de la question
eh bien on risque que sur un monde fini
les arbres ne montent pas jusqu'au ciel
et donc que si on ne gère pas la
régulation de nous mêmes la régulation
s'appliquera par des processus face
auquel dans quelques dizaines d'années
le coffee semblera une aimable
plaisanterie c'est à dire que le système
se régulera lui même il ya une petite
règle de trois jours qui permet de
comprendre si on ne régule pas de
système de nous mêmes sur soi la
sobriété soit la décarbonation
technologique j'ai envie dix ans et qui
sera très très loin de faire l'essentiel
du chemin dans tout la falloir qu'on
devienne sauf si on veut durer et bien à
ce moment-là régulation se fera sur
l'effondrement socio économique et
l'effondrement de la population
l'équation de kaya qui permet de dire ça
donc c'est malheureusement on n'a pas de
troisième voie dans laquelle on pourrait
avoir la croissance perpétuelle qui a
été inventé par des gens parce qu'il
avait vu avec qui ça n'existe pas encore
une fois sur la planète il y donc soit
on régule de nous mêmes soit la
régulation s'exerce au hasard quand elle
a décidé de le faire est sûr qu'il a
décidé de taper en général la deuxième
option
l'histoire nous enseigne qu'elle fait
beaucoup plus de dégâts
la première est au loup alors
premièrement nous avons pas mal de
points communs avec la vision que vient
d'exprimer jean marc jancovici d'une
part sur le prix mort a donné
aujourd'hui à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et qui fait que
nj a récemment adopté une raison d'être
que nous avons inscrit dans nos statuts
et qui dit que l'invocation de
l'entreprise
sa raison d'être et d'agir pour
accélérer la transition vers une
économie neutre en carbone et par des
solutions plus sobres en énergie et plus
respectueuse de l'environnement
alors plus respectueuse de
l'environnement parce que le co2
l'énergie ça n'est qu'une partie de
l'équation
comme l'a dit jean marc jancovici
dans le même temps il faut aussi se
soucier ne pas tuer tous les poissons et
ne pas avoir pollué nos vilains point
insupportable
ceci veut dire que nous mettons
clairement le changement climatique et
la lutte contre le changement climatique
au coeur de nos préoccupations et c'est
un objectif qui n'est pas négociable
nous partageons la vision un peu
apocalyptique si si on rate cette
transition selon rate la réduction
significative des émissions de carbone
l'avenir est assez sombre et que ça
risque de se traduire par des des
catastrophes qui effectivement
réguleront le système mais qu'ils
arriveront un prix extrêmement élevés à
payer pour l'humanité alors ça c'est la
vision globale mais là où on diffère
c'est que nous avons une approche
extrêmement microéconomique est un peu
moins macroscopique que
que jean marc jancovici et parce que
nécessairement nous on regarde ce que
nous demandent nos clients nos clients
qui sont des particuliers qui sont des
entreprises qui sont des collectivités
locales qui sont des universités des
aéroports et nous essayons d'accompagner
nos clients très concrètement avec des
solutions qui leur permettent
d'exploiter au mieux les ressources
locales
parce que les ressources qui peuvent
être exploitées à romorantin et abu
dhabi ne sont pas les mêmes qui
permettent de résoudre au maximum le
problème du client c'est-à-dire
satisfaire un besoin donné au mieux avec
le moins d'émissions possible et au
passage avec des coûts raisonnables qui
permet aussi de s'adapter à la vision
politique locale parce que parmi les
éléments que nous ne contrôlons pas en
tant qu'entreprise il ya le contexte
macroéconomique
il ya le contexte politique ce ne sont
pas les entreprises qui votent pour
ni les gouvernements dans les pays
démocratiques ni les gouvernements dans
les pays non démocratiques ni ni pour le
président des états unis qui influencent
l'ensemble du monde donc on s'adapte
aussi aux politiques qu'ils sont
déterminés par les élus que ce soit des
politiques nationales que seraient des
politiques locales voire micro local et
enfin dernier point sur lequel on a un
contrôle que partiel l'évolution
technologique et de ce point de vue là
on est peut-être nous sommes peut-être
en tant qu'entreprise un peu plus
optimiste que cela
vision qu'a exprimée savoir que jean cau
vie ici nous pensons que une partie
significative du chemin vers la
transition vers une économie neutre en
carbone sera fait avec grâce à des
évolutions technologiques favorable
alors on croit pas aux miracles mais on
croit à l'est mais l'or à l'amélioration
continue toute une série de technologies
alors tout ceci nous conduit un ensemble
de convictions qui sont qui relève d'un
certain pragmatisme qui est ralliée au
fait qu' on travaille sur le terrain
avec nos clients sur des problèmes qui
sont très différents qui fait que nous
croyons pas aux solutions uniques
nous pensons que il faut beaucoup
travailler sur le terrain sur chaque
problème pour trouver la meilleure
solution possible de l'équation coup co2
et satisfaction du besoin
nous avons la conviction que le chemin
vers - carbone passe pas plus
d'électrification mais ne passe pas par
le tout électrique et qu' il faut
notamment un équilibre entre différents
vecteurs énergétiques et qu'on aura
besoin de molécules énergétique
pour faire court aujourd'hui du gaz
naturel de main du gaz vers après-demain
de l'hydrogène pour équilibrer les
systèmes et nous croyons beaucoup que la
résilience globale du système est
renforcé par le fait que la
diversification
est en marche que localement on utilise
des ressources différentes et que
globalement on utilise tout un panier de
ressources et de ce point de vue là nous
faisons nôtre la devise de churchill qui
quand il est en tant que lord de
l'amirauté décide de passer la flotte
britannique du charbon nationale au
pétrole importé dit la diversification
et la diversité des la diversification
seul nous apportera la sécurité
d'approvisionnement
notre sentiment c'est que ceci
s'applique de manière générale c'est la
diversification des sources d'énergie
c'est la diversification des solutions
qui apportent globalement de la
résilience au système peut-être juste
pour finir cet exposé liminaire
un exemple sur la mobilité
nous croyons profondément que pour
verdir le besoin de mobilité une
multiplicité de solutions seront en
oeuvre
qu'il s'agisse de gaz naturel liquéfié
demain de bio gnl pour les navires de
haute mer comme la fessée est massé gm
pour ses portes conteneurs mais aussi
pour des camions sur des trajets de
longue distance
qu'ils s'agissent d'hydrogène pour des
camions des taxis comme à paris demain
des avions court courriers des bus comme
à pau
dans certains cas des flottes des
flottes captives à haute intensité de
service qu'il s'agisse bien sûr de
véhicules électriques
les vélos les scooters les voitures qui
ne font que des trajets domicile travail
ou des trajets cours qu'ils s'agissent
de gaz naturel véhicule et demain de bio
gnv pour une série de deux camions de
petits utilitaires légers qu'ils
s'agissent les zones rurales et des
tracteurs et enfin peut-être demain dei
fuel pour les avions long courriers
parce qu'il faudra bien trouver une
solution pour continuer à faire des vols
long-courriers même si je ne sais pas
dire aujourd'hui en tant qu'entreprise
s'il s'en fera plus moins qu'aujourd'hui
mais il y aura toujours un besoin il
faudra bien trouver une solution
décarbonés aujourd'hui nous en voyons
guère d'autre que les les fuels
reconstitué à partir d'hydrogène co2
voilà sur cet exemple de la mobilité
un exemple de notre approche pragmatique
et est complémentaire et la conviction
que le système sera d'autant plus
résilient qu'on aura cette
complémentarité de solution avant de
passer à des points de débat plus précis
est ce que jean marc jancovici est des
commentaires à faire se souvient de dire
didier oh oui j'en ai un certain nombre
mais j'ai peur que si je commence à les
lister tous dans le détail on dépasse
l'horaire des visites dans quelques
commentaires très rapide j'ai deux
jambes toutes les deux fait d'os et de
muscles si moment coupe une pour la
remplacer par une jambe de bois
j'ai augmenté la diversité de mes appuis
je ne suis pas du tout persuadé que j'ai
augmenté ma résilience globale de la
diversité c'est pas un argument
d'autorité pour moi ça dépend parfois on
repasse la deuxième chose c'est que
prendre des initiatives qu'on énonce
c'est vachement bien
mais moi si j'ai un enfant qui dans le
même temps commence à sécher tous les
cours mais améliore ses notes dans la
seule matière qui ne siège pas je suis
pas complètement sûr non plus qui va
dans la bonne direction
au moins il ya qu un seul juge de paix
c'est on instaure une comptabilité
carbone exhaustive aussi granulaire que
la comptabilité économique et on regarde
d'un air essence n va parce que évident
dans une entreprise il ya des trucs qui
vont bien les trucs qui vont moins bien
être et clément dans la bonne direction
des trucs qui vont dans la mauvaise et
aujourd'hui je suis désolé de le dire
les entreprises passent leur temps à
égrainer ce qui va bien qui est une part
dominante microscopique de leur activité
sans jamais rené pressent en place
pectine dans l'ensemble des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre dont elles
dépendent donc si dans le même temps
qu'eux ont fait un avion à hydrogène en
2035 parce qu'on n'en fera pas quatre
milliards de passagers par an les ordres
de grandeur l'interdît super parier
toutes les économies à eux
écoutant ce webinaire c'est pas ça qui
va se passer on continue à augmenter l
usage du gaz naturel dans le monde qui
tout naturel qu'il est l'élu co2 pour la
génération électrique
on n'a pas résolu le problème pour le
moment quand on regarde les émissions
planétaires de gaz à effet de serre il
n'y a pas une seule innovation technique
depuis un siècle et demi qui a inversé
la courbe
pas même lui même un ensemble la cour va
augmenter parce que il ya pas de raison
à ça donc je je je pense pour ma part
que une chose qui est urgente dans cette
affaire et je suis désolé de le drian
quelqu'un qui pariera clients c'est
qu'il faut que les entreprises arrêtent
urgemment d'égrener la liste de leurs
bonnes actions
au lieu de se doter des outils de
pilotage copal royal et les actions qui
comptera six pour la com
pas pour le pilotage des problèmes et
peut-être une réponse
cela n'empêche pas l'autre et nous on
les y est justement là empêche l'autre
parce que ça occupe tout l'espace
temporel
non pas du tout du tout je dire la
baisse la baisse de nos émissions
globales
de gaz à effet de serre qui est
effectivement un objectif sur lequel
nous travaillons et cette comptabilité à
laquelle jean-marc faisait allusion nous
y travaillons elle passe par des
fermetures de centrales à charbon elle
passe par des actions de conversion de
centrales à charbon des centrales à gaz
parce que l'air de rien on gagne quand
même la moitié du co2 émis
alors c'est ça serait mieux de passer
tout de suite une centrale à hydrogène
ou à une autre ennemi de forme
d'émission mais ça n'est pas toujours
possible
enfin les projets auxquels se réfère en
nacre et en s'écriant la centrale à
hydrogène c'est un circuit fermé parce
que l'hydrogène est faite de
l'électricité ou en réformant du méthane
et as commencé pire question co2 des
centrales électriques pour faire
l'électricité pour faire vivre aux
jeunes qui alimente la centrale
électrique pas complètement convaincu
que ça va marcher
j'ai peur qu'on perde le fil d'acier did
you love finition commentaires et après
on va passer à pouvoir parler des heures
à parler l'hydrogène comme moyen de
stocker l'électricité mais mais dans
l'immédiat nous notre point de vue très
pragmatique c'est que si on a l'occasion
de réduire pour la même consommation
électrique
l'émission de co2 en passant d'une
centrale à charbon d'une centrale à gaz
il faut le faire tout de suite et pas
forcément attendre d'avoir la solution
zéro carbone
mais maintenant parce que je ne sais pas
ce que je dis ça y est non mais je pas
dit le contraire je dis juste nous en
tant qu'entreprise ont fait on est de
nos clients et ont fait nous mêmes les
pas qu'on peut faire le plus vite
possible pour réduire l'empreinte
carbone
mon coin de mon poing et de dire dans la
comptabilité monétaire je n'ai jamais vu
une entreprise mais pour pérenniser
qu'une partie de ces opérations qui sont
celles qui vont dans le bon sens une
portabilité monétaire ont comme tous les
produits et les charges on sait
exactement tout est normalisée et à la
fin du fin on sait quelle signification
on doit donner aux résultats
ce que je dis c'est que en matière de
comptabilité carbone à peu près aucune
entreprise non mais là et c'est délibéré
parce que c'est parce que ça coûte
compte tenu de l'enjeu est d'éviter ce
soir aux tirs c'est vraiment parce que
ça coûte parfois de le faire revenir
juste sur ce point
un travail 2 c'est plus compliqué et on
peut pas le résoudre avec des formules à
l'emporte-pièce
je prends juste un exemple comme bien
faire et c'était très compliqué quand
nous reproche oui mais justement on a du
mal à appliquer un certain nombre de nos
cantons mais en fait quand même quand on
reprend chez un industriel
une installation qui marche au charbon
qui nous confient en l'état et qu'on va
investir à sa place pour la convertir à
des économies plus propre on commence
par augmenter notre bilan carbone parce
que cette cette solution charbon qui
était dans le bilan carbone de
l'industriel elle passe dans l'autre
donc ça je suis désolé mais ensuite
quand on a des investisseurs il faut
allez leur expliquer dans le détail
pourquoi et comment donc ça n'est pas
aussi simple et de dire simplement il
suffirait que toutes les entreprises
fassent et réduisent concrètement si je
reprends une installation carbonées un
mes clients pour la décarbonés je
commence par augmenter mon bilan tarbes
non non ça me change de ça change de
compte mais ça ça change pas le papa le
bain il était pour l'entreprise il
n'était pas chez moi il n'est pas chez
moi
oui mais dans un bilan carbone ya pas
que les éditions qui se
équipement la propriété d'entreprises
toutes les émissions dont elle dépend
donc c'est justement un inventaire de
toutes les émissions qui sont liées à
des processus qui sont nécessaires au
fonctionnement des entreprises clientes
il crie on travaillait pas avec moi
avant vienne pas s'ils ne travaillaient
pas s'il fallait pas je suis d'acord oui
donc tu donc c'est compliqué c'est tout
ce que je veux dire c'est ce n'est pas
aussi simple c'est comme en matière à ce
moment il faut faire des comptes pro
forma c'est pas bon je vous propose de
parler du nucléaire
je crois que jean marc jancovici est un
écologiste un peu singulier dans le sens
où c'est un grand défenseur du nucléaire
et que moi j'ai entendu dire à
l'occasion à 10 kilos
le nucléaire c'est pas forcément si
formidable que ce qu'on veut bien dire
parce que didier hall peu à la question
c'est est-ce que le nucléaire représente
une marge de manoeuvre décisive ou un
modeste contributeurs à la
transformation énergétique
alors ok - nous considérons que le
nucléaire est une arme utile dans la
transition
[Musique]
ceci est complètement cohérent avec le
fait que nous sommes l'opérateur des
centrales nucléaires belges et que nous
pensons que notamment pour la belgique
il serait utile et pour globalement le
bien de la planète de prolonger quelques
tranches nucléaires belges
au delà de 2025 même si c'est bien
entendu et j'ai insisté tout à l'heure
une décision qui dépendent du parlement
et du gouvernement belge en l'occurrence
et donc c'est quelque chose que nous ne
contrôlons pas dans les belles soit
décider souverainement mais nous pensons
que ça améliorer le bilan carbone de la
belgique et donc du monde 6
mon projet c'est un deuxième point
nous constatons que il n'est pas
forcément raisonnable d'avoir dans un
mix énergétique donné dans un mixer les
cris donner une part trop grande d'une
seule technologie et en l'occurrence
qu'il s'agisse du nucléaire ou d'une
autre en particulier parce que nous
pensons que le nucléaire peut poser des
risques de disponibilité systémique et
que donc il n'est pas raisonnable de
confier une part trop importante du mix
au niveau de ce point de vue là nous
pensons que le nucléaire doit être une
composante d'un mix équilibré dans les
pays qui le choisissent troisième point
alors là si on regarde macroscopiquement
nous serons au constat qu'il y à 2000
gigawatts de centrales électriques à
charbon dans le monde et que il ya tout
au plus 200 gigawatts de projets
nucléaires dans le monde
donc dans le meilleur des cas c'est tous
les projets nucléaires viennent à leur
terme d'ici 10 à 15 ans on aura résolu
discours semble du problème posé par les
centrales à charbon
nous en tant qu'énergie nous avons
décidé nous consacrer plutôt 90 autres %
c'est-à-dire de chercher les moyens de
réduire l'empreinte carbone de la
production énergétique en nous attaquant
et en proposant d'autres solutions que
les solutions nucléaire tout en
reconnaissant qu'une partie du chemin
sera fait par le nucléaire
pourquoi est-ce qu'un très résumé peu
notre position d'ensemble
pourquoi est-ce que le nucléaire n'est
pas une solution quand tu as dit c'est
le deuxième point une solution
raisonnable
est ce que c'est un ace que
économiquement il est il facile pour une
entreprise de se brider de se lancer
dans le nucléaire
deux choses au plan économique c'est pas
impossible et ça s'est fait à l'époque
on constate quand même que du point de
vue des risques et du point de vue
politique c'est très compliqué d'être un
opérateur privé de nucléaire
deuxièmement le nucléaire historique
pour toute une série de raisons à des
coûts qui sont relativement compétitifs
en tout cas raisonnable le nucléaire 9il
malheureusement une technologie qui est
très cher et ceci nous paraît un autre
facteur limitant au développement futur
futur du nucléaire
jean-marc alors je quelques éléments en
différentiel je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec le fait que le nucléaire
est au fond une énergie et une industrie
d'état c'est à dire que de faire reposer
sur un acteur privé qui va pouvoir
trouver des capitaux avec un coût du
capital significativement supérieur par
construction à celui de l'état renchérit
considérablement le nucléaire parce que
pour donner un exemple à une clé paint
en bretagne l'essentiel du coût du
mégawattheure c'est en fait c'est du
coût de l'argent
c'était parce que l'argent est
disponible dans environ 10 % de
rendement annuel exigé s'il était si
tout le monde considérait que le
nucléaire très désirable pressure en
termes politiques internes techniques
etc et que l'on disait 1% c'est bien
c'est lui qui a pas de risques de
dérapages majeurs sur le coût de
construction et que ça ramène un peu
plus que les obligations allemandes à ce
moment le goût du mégawattheure avec le
même coût de construction descend en
dessous de 50 euros
donc le le coût du nouveau nucléaire est
essentiellement un coût du risque perçu
par des opérateurs privés
quand je suis tout à fait d'accord c'est
pas un sujet d'opérateurs privés c'est
un sujet de puissance publique
et puis de toute façon c'est une filière
très longue donc dans un contexte
politique où c'est géré à la petite
semaine
c'est le cas en france depuis 20 ans
c'est risqué au chic et en belgique soit
dit en passant eh bien on finit par
avoir des conflits donc là dessus je
suis d'accord le deuxième point que je
voudrais indiquer c'est que on a un
débat en france sur le nucléaire qui sur
représente considérablement les risques
par rapport à la réalité
ou plus exactement qu'il est qui leur
donne un caractère bien excessif par
rapport à tout un tas d'autres risques
concours tous les jours sans trop se
poser de questions sans se poser le même
même niveau de risques les écologistes
contribue beaucoup à sir opposante et ce
alors je n'aime pas appeler les gens qui
se soucient du long terme des
écologistes parce qu'en l'occurrence là
il s'agit pas d écologie ça pénalise
agit des antinucléaires une catégorie de
la particulière d'acteurs deux traites
se recouvrent largement avec ce qu'on a
coutume d'appeler l'écologie politique
le faible se recouvrent largement avec
ce qu'on a coutume d'appeler l'écologie
associative
mais je pense que les lignes sont un peu
en train de changer de ceux de ce point
de vue complètement
il ya énormément malentendu par exemple
encore il ya un an je pense que c'est
maintenant il y avait un sondage bibi un
sondage qui a montré que tous pensaient
sur 3do mémoire trois sur quatre
je pensais que le nucléaire était un
ventre et buteur significatif ou
important aux émissions de gaz à effet
de serre parce que ça par exemple
évidemment change totalement la
confusion qui convient d'en tirer dans
le cadre de la big bang au changement
climatique
donc il ya il ya un débat sur necker qui
est un débat compliqué à cause de ça ce
à quoi je ne crois pas alors je vais
terminer guillot l'eau a dit
il ya 200 gigawatts de projets pour 2011
plus de 2200 kg en fait j awad de
centrales à charbon dans le monde il a
tout à fait raison de souligner sable et
moi je vais compléter par la conclusion
logique parce qu'il vient me dire il est
absolument évident que nous n'avons
strictement aucune chance de respecter
les deux degrés si l'essentiel de la
planète se met pas en l'économie guerre
c'est totalement évident on voit pas
l'ombre d'un débat pour moi là dessus
donc ça veut dire qu'on sera si on veut
respecter cet objectif nécessairement
dans un cadre beaucoup plus planifiés et
beaucoup plus dirigiste c'est ça le prix
à payer si on veut éviter que ça se
termine carnage il dans ce contexte là
alors là par contre je me prépare une
seconde qu'on puisse pas remplacer une
fraction significative les 2000
gigawatts des 8 200 gigawatts part du
nucléaire dans ce contexte la voilà mais
dans un contexte dans lequel de toute
façon on dit ça sera ce que ça sera
parce que c'est le marché qui domine et
sera de toute façon on fera au
casse-pipe contexte c'est un cas dans
lequel qu'il y ait 200 gigawatts 250 ou
300 le nucléaire par de plus haut en
termes de production électrique
aujourd'hui que l'éolien et le solaire
et pourtant tout le monde compte sur
l'éolien le solaire donc s'ils décident
eux seuls sujets ce niveau de départ
il faut tout de suite mettre à la
poubelle éolien et solaire
ce qui par ailleurs l indice vous êtes
des barbares
le point important les vraies limites à
mon avis est par ailleurs le camp de ce
sont les chinois ou les goréens qui
construisent c'est à dire n'ayant pas
encore l'habitude français sur nucléaire
qui n'est pas le prime du guerre
mondiale ils construisent les réacteurs
pour la moitié ou le tiers du coût que
les français sont capables d'atteindre
donc c'est qu'on a aussi un sujet
strictement français sur cette question
le père a quand même trop compliqué ça a
été fait en collaboration avec les
allemands qui voulaient ceinture et
orientale paprec à dire là dessus
maintenant si vous renversez
raisonnement qui est est-ce qu'on a la
moindre chance de faire sauter le
couvercle de la cocotte minute sans
recourir le plus possible le plus vite
possible au nucléaire ma réponse est non
donc j'ai envie de répondre de conclure
cette intervention dans madame est
rassurant en disant plus on en fait et
moins je me fais toutes proportions
gardées de cheveux blancs pour mes
enfants pour lesquels je m'en fais pas
mal voilà c'est comme ça que j'ai envie
de dire c'est que si on compare les
risques de faire avec les risques de ne
pas faire et en particulier le risque de
ne pas faire de nucléaire parce qu'on
pense que l'éolien le solaire ça ira
plus vite de supprimer de richie a white
niggaz à l'éolien à peu importe moi je
dis non ce qui aura le plus vite c'est
de dire c'est de prendre du nucléaire la
vraie limite au nucléaire dans ce
contexte là je la rue dit elle est
double pour moi hein ça doit se faire
dans le cadre d'une puissance publique
volontaire est constante et de on a un
petit sujet sur leurs ressources en
uranium
parce que tant qu'on est à 4 100
gigawatts nucléaire installée leur
demande c'est pas un suggéré leur même
mais par ailleurs les loups de l'air
n'est pas discriminant et si on veut
qu'il devienne discriminant on va avoir
un sujet sur la disponibilité du régime
de 135 donc il faut passer très vite à
la génération d'après qu'est-ce qui est
technologiquement possible
donc je ne suis pas du tout un ennemi la
technologie je suis un ami de
l'évaluation ex ante et avant de
déployer une technologie des avantages
et des inconvénients
dans un contexte de temps limité et de
moyens ni les jeux je vais passer à part
la did you know pour faire un avantage
tout commentaire et après je vous
propose de changer un petit peu leur de
prévu de parler directement des énergies
renouvelables dont électriques dont
jancovici a dit que ce n'était pas grand
chose d'utile
didier win
encore une fois notre point de vue il
n'est pas il y avait encore une lampe
économique donc mois ci pour débattre
aussi les mieux pour le monde de
cueillir une espèce de d'autorité
capable de décider qu'on allait faire
massivement du nucléaire pour remplacer
le charbon dans le cas d'une économie de
guerre dont acte
il ya la moitié du parc mondial qui est
potentiellement concerné par cet aspect
là puisque la moitié du par charbon en
chine qui est un pays rêvé l'allemand
dirigiste oui mais enfin il ya là une
bonne partie qui sont dans des pays
d'asie du sud est qui sont dans des pays
d'amérique latine qui sont qui sont
encore en australie qui sont et c'est
donc par ailleurs je pense que il ya une
vraie question de capacité à faire de
dire je ne crois pas que toute
l'industrie nucléaire y compris les
coréens les chinois les russes puissent
faire plus de 15 des acteurs parents 20
réacteurs parents en économie tranquille
longue on est premier devant dieu et
donc on a un vrai problème de passage à
l'échelle qui fait que de toute façon
et puis et s'il faut en plus attendre la
prochaine génération on a un problème de
timing qui fait que de toute façon pour
travailler sur les autres solutions
entre temps et donc ça nous amène à la
transition vers qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire
entre temps et nous notre conviction
c'est que il faut continuer à travailler
sur les énergies renouvelables
électriques et non électriques et notre
sentiment c'est que on est très très
loin d'avoir fait tout ce qu'on pouvait
en énergies renouvelables autre que le
photovoltaïque et l'éolien
même si convaincu qu'il faut faire du
photovoltaïque et l'éolien on peut en
parler mais je prends je prends juste un
exemple aujourd'hui en projet de
biométhane en france il ya 25
térawattheures de projets qui ne demande
qu'à être lancée 25 térawattheures c'est
l'équivalent de la production d'un peu
plus que deux tranches nucléaires en
france donc c'est pas négligeable
c'est pas non plus considérable à ce
stade notre conviction est basée sur les
études de l'ademe c'est que le potentiel
en france est de l'ordre de 140
térawattheures par an c'est-à-dire au
total quatorze tranches nucléaires pour
faire court donc c'est très très loin
d'être négligeable
c'est du calibre de la production de gaz
en temps par 240 térawatts heure où on
parle de la production électrique tiré
du gaz
on parle de notre production de biogaz
est alors si on convertit sa en
électricité pour comparer avec les trans
nucléaire faut diviser par deux sauf
qu'on a aucune raison pour les usages
thermiques de convertir en électricité
il est beau quand nous rassure mais
horribilis nex je suis d'accord oui ou
non racheter un montage minoritaires ok
c'est minoritaire dans la consommation
électrique 1 mais ok c'est minoritaire
dans la consommation électrique c'est
très loin d'être minoritaire de la
consule dans la consommation énergétique
française
l'ongle non mais je comparais des
centrales nucléaires juste pour dire on
est quand même dans des ordres de
grandeur ou on parle de choses sérieuses
oui moi je préfèrerais comparé à la
consommation de gaz fossile mais on met
alors parlons de la consommation de gaz
fossile
pour nous ça représente en gros un tiers
de la consommation gaz aujourd'hui et ça
représente la moitié de la consommation
de gaz que nous imaginons 2050
parce qu'on pense que la consommation de
gaz va globalement se réduire sous les
sous l'influencé essentiellement que
l'efficacité énergétique donc
donc ce sont des ordres de grandeur qui
sont significatives deuxième source
d'énergie
aujourd'hui négligés ou insuffisamment
exploité ce qu'on appelle en général
sous le nom de chaleur renouvelable qui
composait essentiellement de chaleur
fatale industrielle d'un côté et
géothermie de l'autre deux énergies qui
sont très smooth utilisé en france et
pour lequel nous nous avons des exemples
très concrets qu'ils s'agissent de
réseaux de chaleur et de froid qu'il
s'agisse du zonage industriel
d'optimisation de process industriels
dans lesquels on peut gagner
considérablement donc notre sentiment
c'est que là aussi le potentiel dans ces
domaines là est tout à fait considérable
est sous-exploité troisième sujet le
solaire thermique
c'est quand même frappant quand vous
promener un peu partout autour du bassin
méditerranéen dans tous les pays sauf la
france
l'eau chaude sanitaire et produit pas du
solaire thermique
il y a qu'en france que le solaire
thermique est très peu utilisé alors ça
n'a l'air de rien mais le solaire
thermique c'est quand même c'est quand
même un méga 1 mégawatt par par maisons
par an donc un mégawatt heure pardon par
maisons par an donc on peut facilement
réduire les consommations
et ceci avec une énergie entièrement
renouvelable est très largement
disponibles parce que le soleil tu le
solaire thermique ça marche même les
jours où le soleil est voilée et on
arrive quand même à avoir des
températures d'eau chaude sanitaire tout
à fait acceptable avec des systèmes
relativement simple voilà un exemple des
ressources qui permettent de satisfaire
toute une série de besoins et qui sont
aujourd'hui sous-exploité quand on
commence à cumuler tout ça on arrive à
des contributions qui sont tout à fait
significative et qui surtout client par
client permettent des réductions
d'émissions de co2 considérable encore
une fois notre responsabilité l epa
macroscopique même si à la fin cet
accord qu'il faut il faut que l'équation
re boucle mais nous sommes absolument
convaincus qu'en travaillant sur chacun
des projets avec chacun des clients
on optimise globalement le système et on
réduit globalement l'empreinte carbone
tout en satisfaisant bonne quantité de
besoins qui sont des besoins que les
clients continuent à exprimer
quand tu mets en relation c'est toutes
ses ressources avec les jd des centrales
à charbon chan a changé au niveau dans
le monde sait c'est un pouillème où
c'est significatif alors très
honnêtement si on veut directement
substituer des centrales à charbon
1 il ya un certain nombre de pays où on
peut on a une ressource de biogaz et de
géothermie aux températures qui
permettrait de le faire par exemple
l'indonésie en indonésie un plan de
développement audacieux de la géothermie
haute température plus de la production
de biogaz biomasse
c'est un pays tropical où les plantes
poussent facilement permettrait de
substituer une bonne partie de la
production charbon dans d'autres pays
c'est évidemment plus compliqué au
moyen-orient par exemple on n'a guère de
solutions de substitution au gaz naturel
donc le mieux qu'on puisse faire c'est
dans un certain nombre de ces pays de
supprimer le charbon de le remplacer par
le gaz naturel à court terme mais
sachant d'ici 2050 pour trouver d'autres
solutions qui peuvent être du biogaz
peuvent être d'autres technologies pour
substituer à son tour la centrale à gaz
naturel par une autre source des
derniers mois ce qui effectivement on
peut pas remplacer tout de suite comme
ça massivement les centrales à charbon
par d'autres alternatives
sauf le gaz naturel c'est le plus rapide
pour la plupart des grilles bon ben
alors quelque peu de considération
d'ensemble moi je vais reprendre un
point de vue macro habitude la première
considération c'est que la révolution
industrielle a consisté à passer de la
mobilisation du sol à la mobilisation du
sous sol pour la fourniture d'énergie
aux machines qui ont fait l'écho système
industriel dans lequel nous vivons
aujourd'hui
du coup on a libéré la totalité du sol
pour nourrir les gens ou pour accueillir
des espaces on appelle entre guillemets
sauvages c'est-à-dire ceux qui hébergent
la biodiversité partir du moment où on
récupère du sol pour fournir de
l'énergie
c'est dire que la photosynthèse n'est
pas affectée et à l'alimentation ya la
préservation des espèces naturelles
ça veut dire qu'on rentre en compétition
avec les deux usages que je viens
d'évoquer
c'est à dire manger et préserver des
espaces naturels
donc globalement aujourd'hui à la
surface de la planète
si la forêt qui est en train de céder la
place
aux cultures qui sont pour partie à
vocation alimentaire et pour partie à
vocation énergétique alors que les
américains par exemple c'est pas un papa
de yoga aujourd'hui 40 % du maïs qui
cultivent parle dans un réservoir d'eau
étudiants donc là on voit aussi que dans
les marges de manoeuvre on a le choix
entre diminuer le visage à laval ou
maintenir un usage à laval c'est
caricatural parce qu'on peut faire un
peu des données ou maintenir des usages
à laval et essayer de convertir la
source d'énergie qu'on utilise vers une
source que non pense décarbonés mais
aujourd'hui en fait si on regarde
macroscopiquement dès qu'on fait une
culture énergétique comme on conserve le
même niveau de bonshommes sur terre et
même niveau de culture pour
l'alimentation aux variations de
rendement très mais qui sont pas énormes
aujourd'hui en l'essentiel des pays du
monde et bien ça veut dire que on a un
effet l'intro skotnik de prix sur la
forêt et les cultures
alors tout ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas se servir de la biomasse mais
il faut s'en servir avec des conditions
aux limites qui sont à mon avis beaucoup
plus importante celle qu'on met
aujourd'hui
et par ailleurs il faut s'en servir une
fois qu'on n'a pas réussi à décarbonés
pour faire autre chose car je prends un
exemple très franco français jacques
chez nous en france j'ai fait un rapide
calcul montrant que si on voulait
remplacer la totalité des chaudières au
gaz et au fioul par des pompes à chaleur
on pouvait faire ça avec un modeste
accroissement du parc nucléaire et on se
débarrasse de 60% du gaz fossile donc
60% du gaz fossile c'est les deux tiers
des 450 dira water valeur et donc c'est
deux fois plus que les 150
térawattheures on pourrait faire avec du
biogaz est ce que ça veut dire qu'il
faut pas faire lever gaz non mais dans
ma vision il faut le réserver à des
usages dans lequel c'est beaucoup plus
difficile beaucoup plus lent ce qui est
et ce qui revient au même
de décarbonés avec de l'électricité ou
avec un autre moyen
il ya quelques quelques usages auxquels
je pense il ya notamment des usages de
niche de mobilité par exemple qui me
semble plus à court terme le premier
utilisateur du biogaz devraient être les
agriculteurs eux mêmes les engins
mécanisés qu'ils continueront d'utiliser
tant que les deux tiers de la population
seront pas retournés au chant voilà donc
je pense qu'il faut être beaucoup plus
discriminée aujourd'hui c'est là qu'il
faut établir un ordre de mérite
et puis 10 tant que je peux en faire
sans nuire à des objectifs concurrents
je commence par ça puis une fois que ce
truc là je me suis débarrassé du
problème à ce moment je passe un truc en
dessous et la liste de préférences doit
être établi lorsque je donne est un mode
de gestion qui dépend évidemment de pays
en fonction des pays et on n'a pas les
villages qui étaient payants chauffe pas
les pieds plats mais on établit une
liste de préférences et en fonction des
possibilités de substitution pour les
autres usages et de l'ordre de
préférence on en utilise un peu les
allemands par exemple font plein de
biogaz
sauf qu'ils utilisent pour faire
d'électricité pendant vidéo le parlais
je viens de regarder les chiffres là un
peu plus de 50 des rats watts heure
d'électricité au gaz au biogaz qui veut
dire qu'ils sont à peu près 100
térawattheures le gaz produit les chants
allemands
sauf que pour ça il utilise 3 % de la
surface allemande je pense bêtement mois
comme citoyen préférerais qu'ils gardent
leur nucléaire et qu'ils augmentent leur
nucléaire et que ces trois pour cent le
biais d'efforts et de diversité dedans
et du voyage
voilà peu discuté de ce genre de choses
me semble utile et je le redis ça se
place dans un contexte dans lequel s'est
pas on fait ça
et du coup le fait sans perte
d'opportunité sur votre objectif je le
redis on est mené dans un arbitrage
global concurrence usage
et on iran parce que la révolution
industrielle a été l'abandon du sol pour
l'approvisionnement énergétique sur ce
point rappeler que le potentiel de 140
térawattheures auquel je faisais
allusion qui résulte de l'étude aden de
il est bien entendu pas basé sur des
cultures dédiées mais bien basé sur les
déchets agricoles et des cultures
intermédiaires à vocation énergétique
qui ont le double mérite d'être
favorables à la biodiversité d'être
favorable à la préservation du sol et au
stockage du co2 dans le sol enfin
stockage du carbone dans le sol pour
être exact deuxièmement pour nous il est
clair que le fait de produire du biogaz
doit pas entraîner le fait qu'on
gaspille et donc il ya des usages sur
lequel on peut trouver de meilleures
utilisations ou de solutions plus
efficaces
c'est pourquoi nous pensons que des
centrale à biogaz pour faire la pointe
ça peut avoir du sens parce que ça donne
de la flexibilité à la pointe et
centrale qui peuvent démarrer rapidement
mais ça fait peu de volume de biogaz
puisque par déficiente centrale de
pointe elle tourne pas beaucoup
de la même façon si on parle de logement
nous pensons que d'une part le biogaz
reste une solution très adapté en
logements collectifs et si on parle en
logement individuel la bonne solution
pour nous c'est des solutions de type
pack hybride c'est-à-dire en mi-saison
ça fonctionne comme une pompe à chaleur
et quand on est à la pointe de froid qui
est la zone où la pompe à chaleur
ar voit son rendement se dégrader très
fortement et contribue donc fortement à
la pointe électrique c'est la chaudière
qui prend
le relais et qui permet de d'assurer le
confort en pointe de froid sans
contribuer à la pointe électrique
c'est d'ailleurs une solution qu'un
certain nombre de plombier on met en
oeuvre de manière j'ai un peu sauvage en
rajoutant une pompe à chaleur un des
gens qui ont déjà une chaudière à gaz et
ça permet de combiner le meilleur des
deux mondes est d'arriver à une solution
très décarbonée parce qu'elle ne prend
ni sur la pointe électrique qui est en
france très carbonée parce que lapointe
n'est pas fournie par le nucléaire ni ni
de gros volumes de biogaz puisqu'elle
consomme du biogaz qu'à la pointe ce qui
ne crée pas de gros volumes donc nous
sommes très favorables à ce que on
promeut les usages les plus efficaces
pour utiliser au mieux le biogaz
mais le point sur lequel je voulais
assister ce qui n'est pas en compétition
avec les cultures vivrières
ils pointent deux que c'est une solution
qui en plus toutes les séries
d'externalités positives
j'ai souligné son influence sur la
pointe électrique mais il ya aussi la
création de l'emploi en zone rurale il
ya aussi l'amélioration de la
biodiversité et du stockage de co2 dans
le sol
il ya aussi la limitation des
importations de gaz naturel enfin il ya
toute une série d'avantagés annexe à
promouvoir ce type d'énergie qui fait
que nous y sommes très attachés
nous sommes en train de devenir un des
acteurs majeurs du développement du
biogaz en france qui pour l'instant est
encore modeste mais qui a de très
grandes ambitions comme je vais exprimer
tout à l'heure je vois qu'on a un petit
peu dérivé mais un détail me mets juste
quand même au passage j'ai noté sauf
erreur de ma part qu'on n'a pas parlé de
deux choses très à la mode qui sont le
photovoltaïque photovoltaïque et
l'éolien comme si c'était tout ça un peu
secondaire par rapport aux autres
sources d'énergie d'électricité
ce qui à qui la parole dès qu'il apprend
à on ni l'un ni l'autre n'a parlé
vraiment ni d'éolien nice de
photovoltaïque va on est stressés on est
bon on est mal élevé de maternité en
question non mais les énergies
alternatives sont partis alors si tu
veux que je alors nous évidemment
thorgan j nous croyons beaucoup au
photovoltaïque qui à l'éolien nous
sommes le premier développeur de
photovoltaïque et l'éolien en france
nous croyons en particulier qu'une
partie significative de l'avenir de
l'éolien offshore
d'une part parce qu'il ya plus de vent
offshore et que donc une éolienne
offshore tourner jusqu'à 90% du temps ce
qui résout quand même une bonne partie
des problèmes d'intermittence et qui
d'autre part compense par une plus
grande production les coûts plus élevés
d'être installée au short sur le
photovoltaïque
nous considérons que il a encore
d'énormes services à rendre
nous pensons que son rendement va
continuer à s'accroître que les coûts de
la filière peuvent continuer à baisser
ce qui fait que nous voyons déjà du
photovoltaïque dans des pays très
ensoleillée à moins de 20 dollars le
mégawattheure nous pensons qu'un jour en
france on sera en dessous 30 euros le
mégawattheure
en photovoltaïque et donc nous pensons
que c'est une énergie continue à se
développer d'autant plus qu' il y a des
solutions pour réduire son empreinte au
sol ou pour les exactement pour que son
empreinte au sol ne soit pas en
compétition directe avec d'autres usages
du sol il ya suffisamment de terrains
dégradés de friches industrielles de
talus d'autoroute et autres surfaces
inutilisées on peut certainement utilisé
pour faire de la production
photovoltaïque il ya des solutions du
type de l'agro photovoltaïsme qui
permettent de concilier culture et et
photovoltaïque
donc nous pensons que ces énergies sont
encore un très gros potentiel
que ce soit en france ou dans d'autres
pays du monde une des solutions que nous
voyons se développer c'est évidemment
des très grandes fermes solaires par
exemple en australie occidentale ou dans
le désert d'atacama au chili ou demain
dans le sahara pour exporter de la
production vers des zones de
consommation proche ou vers des zones de
consommation aux lointaines à condition
de résoudre le problème du vecteur de
transport qui ont lui-même nécessite
quelques progrès technologiques
son manche je vais commencer par dire
quelque chose que j'aurais pu tout aussi
bien dire tout à fait au début de cet
échange
la limite des 2 degrés qui aujourd'hui
est une limite à laquelle je suis sûr
que angie souscrit publiquement dans ce
giro publiquement s'en fout complètement
et silva échauffement 7 3 ou 4 à 6 soit
il s'est directement la question à mon
interlocuteur
parce que c'est pas le cas
elle emporte avec elle à quelque chose
on disait tout à l'heure où est-ce qu'on
n'échappera pas à prague ou de la
physique et l emporte avec elle quelque
chose qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est que
les émissions plabennec la des terres
doivent devenir nul dans la deuxième
moitié du xxième siècle et ça si on se
place sur un scénario où une régulation
ne sont pas assurées par des copies de
successifs mais de façon continue ça
veut dire que en gros où j'étais un
grand mur auquel ils sont que les
émissions planétaires baisse de 5% par
an il faut qu'on soit passé par la
munition par trop en 2005 en gros sur
une autre âge donc les générations
futures existent elles existent mais
elles depuis 20 ans on les voit tous les
jours à la maison dans son pire encore
leurs enfants à la maison et jean on y
voit tout le temps le 5 % par an alors
5% c'est ce qu'on va avoir cette année à
cause du coc vide donc il faut bien voir
que le rythme de baisse
auxquels il faut qu'on parvienne
planétairement si on veut respecter les
données c'est un covit supplémentaires
par an l'ordre de grandeur
toutefois avoir en tête c'est pour ça
que je parlais tout à l'heure d'économie
guerre il est absolument évident si
large partie des pays de la planète n'en
font pas le premier point structurants
douleur peut pique bien le premier est
que tout ce qui rentre en conflit avec
ça de façon d'irréductibles pas tant
qu'il n'y arrivera jamais le
photovoltaïque comme le nucléaire comme
le gaz vers ce charpentier père à tous
ces débats là pour moi comme le biogaz
s'inscrivent temps est ce que ça nous
aide pas à augmenter la probabilité
qu'on arrive à respecter cette
trajectoire et je rappelle que à un
degré on a déjà à l'australie la sibérie
et la californie cram au même à deux on
va emballer faut pas croire une seule
seconde que deux à d'être un long fleuve
tranquille et égard a dû au changement
climatique pour augmenter et réfugiés
pour affluer en europe 1 million par
dizaines de millions même à 2 le bassin
méditerranéen à perdre 20% de 100
d'humidité
voilà le groenland a commencé à fondre
et on se battra de toutes façons même à
2 degrés n'importe quoi entre 3 et 10
mètres d'élévation du niveau de la mer
dans quelques siècles
rien qu'à double donc si on veut
respecter ces deux degrés je le redis
c'est un covit supplémentaires par an
est ce que dans cette affaire le bébé
c'est là dedans qu'il fallait mettre 120
milliards en france avec l'éolien
la réponse est non c'est l'exacte
illustration du fait qu'on a commencé
par un truc qui est pas urgent en france
le pv l'éolien ça ne sert qu'à faire
baisser de facteurs de charge du
nucléaire
c'est à dire qu'on double les capex un
cap et que ça qu'on fait enfin un
système à coûts fixes de nucléaire
auquel on rajoute un système à coûts
fixes de pv l'éolien pourquoi produire
plus à la fin de l'année avec les 120
milliards qu'on a engagés sur l'éolien
et le solaire en france on aurait pu
rentrer cyclables la totalité du réseau
routier français de 10 de 10 à lille et
de presse à strasbourg
sans oublier pour parier et aurillac
pour honorer pull tout toumaï et en
france où ses trois fois le prix qu'on
aurait dû payer pour remplacer la
totalité des chaudières au fioul dans ce
pays par des pompes à chaleur est ce que
c'est par salle aurait dû commencer
absolument pas la raison pour laquelle
ça a émergé c'est parce que je me
rappelle très bien
au moment du grenelle de l'environnement
mais avant les gens qui étaient à la
manoeuvre on en revient tout à l'heure
en termes d'associations visibles
étaient toutes des associations
antinucléaires qui vont embrayer sur le
mouvement allemand consistant à dire
notre premier ennemi c'est du nucléaire
jean climatique ça viendra derrière du
reste que j'ai en main ça intéresse des
documents de sortir du nucléaire
début des années 2000 et qui disent si
on remplace le nucléaire par du gaz ça
nous va bien ça augmentera
transitoirement les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mais un simple donc
donc on a eu le pousser vers les
énergies renouvelables
les moins facile à utiliser c'est à dire
celles qui sont diffuses et fatale alors
ils lois de la physique sont implacables
plus une énergie qu'on trouve dans
l'environnement et diffuser fatale plus
elle sera compliqué a exploité par
l'humanité la civilisation industrielle
correspond précisément à l'époque où on
a abandonné les énergies diffusé fatale
pour se tourner vers des énergies
concentré et pilotable donc l'idée qu'on
va garder notre civilisation actuelle
avec des énergies qui fusent et non
pilotable à parier à nouveau toutes mes
économies qui veut c'est un truc qui
n'arrivera jamais à 8 milliards
d'individus 70 ans l'espérance de vie à
la naissance n'est pas comme ça qu'on va
garder théorie c'est une façon d'en
avoir voté une partie
mais pour moi le solaire et l'éolien en
rien ce que j'ai tout à l'heure en fait
sont en compétition avec le nucléaire
puisque c'est d énergie électrique dit
décarbonés et donc d'après question
c'est est-ce que je cours moins de
risques est-ce que je vais avoir moins
d' incendies de forêt - de migration
moins de démocratie qui vont tomber
parce qu'une fois qu'on aura 58 ans
réfugiée en ordre démocratique congo est
absolument évident donc est-ce qu'on va
avoir moins de tout ça si on force sur
d'autres marges de manoeuvre que
l'éolien et le solaire avant de forcer
sur l'éolien le solaire alors pour la
france la réponse est oui sans hésiter
pour tous les pays qui maîtrisent déjà
le nucléaire dont la chine
je parlais tout à l'heure la réponse est
oui sans hésiter une seconde après les
cas de figure dans lesquelles c'est pas
vrai alors effectivement au maroc
ça va probablement beaucoup plus vite de
faire du solaire que de faire du
nucléaire
là ça me va bien dans l'atacama ça va
probablement beaucoup plus vite aussi
chez les chiliens jeu la france
pour moi le problème est réglé on
maîtrise le nucléaire et pour faire du
pilotable bas carbone
le photovoltaïque est une coche pas la
classe pee la table et si on veut leur
rendre pilotable il est absolument pas
question de comparer le coût complet du
photovoltaïque avec le coût complet du
nucléaire ou le coût complet d'autres
choses parce qu'on compare les choux et
les carottes
à ce moment il faut si on veut coût
complet du soleil pour le solaire plus
son stockage et le stockage induit des
pertes
il faut surdimensionné les parcs en
stock et il faut inclure de dispositifs
de stockage et il faut inclure les coûts
de réseau parce qu'on a besoin de
puissance installée plus importante etc
et si on fait le calcul que j'ai fait
est bien mal avec un panneau gratuit
j'insiste même avec un panneau gratuit
un système solaire plus stockage alors
j'ai fait 100 % comparé les heures
devant leur coûte plus cher un système
nucléaire même cher donc le le fait
d'aller d'abord dans le solaire dans les
pays qui maîtrisent le nucléaire pour
moi c'est la démonstration parfaite
qu'on aime qu'on n'a rien compris et
qu'on a une lecture de la hiérarchie des
risques qui est totalement erroné parce
que je le répète on est en train de
mettre en jeu en ce moment avec le
climat les questions de l'espérance de
vie et la taille de la population pour
des milliards d'individus
les pas question d'un à histoires
rapport développement durable j'ai
vraiment question c'est un facteur de
survie
j'insiste là dessus donc le solaire et
l'éolien sont à utiliser si tu attends
solution de transition parce que c'est
pas dans des contexte bien particulier
même à l'échelle du ahly héros une île
des canaries qui a commencé à essayer de
développer de l'éolien avec du stockage
dans les steppes
on n'y arrive pas on a besoin de
générateurs à fuel était le tableau donc
le l'idée qu'on va retourner au moulin à
vent on a utilisé pendant 2000 ans et
est gardé quelque chose qui ressemble
peu ou où on actuelle c'est évidemment à
l'heure pour moi sinon le monde actuel
jusqu'à déjà développé dans le monde des
moulins à vent aurait plus de temps ok
didier premièrement nous nous sommes une
entreprise
nous considérons que il appartient au
gouvernement de faire un certain nombre
de choix et ensuite nous on s'inscrit
dans les choix qui sont ceux du
gouvernement qui se traduisent par le
fait qu'à un moment donné il demande de
développer telle ou telle énergie
deuxièmement je le redis notamment en ce
qui concerne les eaux
nous constatons l'augmentation
progressive des rendements et nous
sommes absolument convaincus que
l'éolien offshore à des perspectives de
progrès à la foire coup un rendement en
continuité de service qui en font une
énergie tout à fait intéressantes pour
le futur
je note au passage que on avait un
moment donné il était courant expliqué
qu'aucun système électrique ne pouvait
vivre avec 30% aux intermittents jour où
le danemark a atteint 40% aux
intermittents on a dû constater qu'ils
le danemark continuer à fonctionner la
marque n'est pas un système fermé sinon
il ya longtemps que son réseau aurait
exposé c'est un morceau de la bac ce
candidat donc il est interconnecté avec
les barrages norvégien et avec les
centrales à charbon allemandes
c'est pas un système faire c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais mais le danemark fait la
preuve aussi que l'éolien offshore ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne des coûts
raisonnables et dans un système
interconnecté
oui mais mais les gens qui nous
expliquait qu' à partir d'une certaine
fraction d'intermittents on n'y arrivait
pas ont dû largement révisé leur
jugement parce qu'il ya quand même un
certain nombre de systèmes qui
fonctionnent deuxième point les
stockages se sont développés alors on
fait un peu de stockage par batterie je
ne crois en aucun cas que ce soit la
solution miracle mais nous nous croyons
beaucoup au stockage sous forme
d'hydrogène
alors certes le stockage sous forme
d'hydrogène à des rendements qui qui
font que je ne récupère pas la totalité
de l'énergie
miami mais si on parle de coûts nous
constatons et toutes les études qu'on a
fait convergent que ce soit celle faut
de gaz for climate que ça soit celle que
nous avons fait nous en interne que
globalement un système qui parient sur
les meilleurs outils du vecteur
électrique et du vecteur gazier et qui
combine les deux c'est à dire la la
capacité de stockage et le transport du
vecteur gazier qu'on parle de méthane le
méthane de biométhane ou de l'hydrogène
et d'autre part le vecteur électrique
est un système qu'il est globalement
beaucoup plus efficace qu'un système
tout électrique
je rappelle quand même que nos amis
d'aînés 10 et de rte bienne a eu deux
d'annoncer un plan d'investissement de
100 milliards sur les 15 ans qui
viennent jusqu'à 2035
donc ça se compare aux 120 milliards que
jean marc jancovici cette cité tout à
l'heure pour le pour le photovoltaïque
parce qu'on oublie un peu de dire qu'à
chaque fois que l'on prône
l'électrification des usages que ce soit
avec du nucléaire ou avec une autre
technologie
il faut derrière construire tous les
réseaux et les systèmes d'optimisation
qui vont avec et que tout ceci n'est pas
gratuit et toutes les études que nous on
monte que si on repose à la fois sur un
vecteur gazier notamment pour le
stockage et le transport et sur un
vecteur électrique ça marche
c'est pourquoi nous pensons que la
solution à long terme c'est qu'une
partie de ses intérêts énergies
intermittentes soit stockée sous forme
d'hydrogène ou de méthane sous une autre
forme moléculaire qui permet de
restituer l'énergie au moment où on en a
besoin
je rappelle quand même parce que là
aussi je rejoins jean marc jancovici
les faits sont têtus les lois de la
physique ne change pas du jour au
lendemain
aujourd'hui à la pointe
deux demandes en france la pointe de
demande énergétique à 8 heures du matin
un hiver froid et 330 gigawatts
le réseau électrique peut en fournir 100
en gros plus ou moins 5
tout le reste bien aujourd'hui de forme
de molécules ou un peu par les réseaux
de chaleur
il vient sous forme de gaz il vient sous
format sepa la pointe électrique sera
privé d'arjen aussi fort oui énergétique
tu as entendu pointe électrique et
énergétique
c'est la pointe de demandes et
énergétique d'un braqueur du à 8 heures
du matin un hiver froid ont manqué leur
en reste et n'en fournit n'ont fourni
qu'un tiers ok donc donc croire qu'on va
pouvoir électrifié tous les usages que
ce soit avec l'unique l'air ou d'autres
pour nous ça ne tient pas et on a besoin
et c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai re
j'y reviens on a besoin nous on croit
fortement que l'éolien et le solaire ont
leur rôle à jouer
on a besoin du nucléaire là où il y en a
sur balles à pointe à pitre sont pas
pilotable à 7 heures du matin solaire en
hiver c'est il est totalement nulle
lagorce sauf que si on a produit de
l'hydrogène pendant l'été ah oui
d'accord c'est bien que disponible
ils ont réintégré donc il faut
réintégrer le coût du stockage dans
cette histoire absolument
mais hélas nous nos convictions ne
rejoignait pas
vos calculs c'est à dire que nous sommes
convaincus que compte tenu de
l'évolution des prix du nucléaire d'un
côté compte tenu de l'évolution des prix
des technologies de l'autre les énergies
électriques intermittente plus le
stockage sous forme d'hydrogène et
compétitif à terme contre les autres
production d'électrité électricité est
pilotable avant de passer la parole à sa
joie juste à bord d un point j'ai vu
plusieurs personnes avaient soulevé la
question
la sobriété énergétique ou les économies
d'énergie c'est quoi c'est marginal
c'est du pipeau ou c'est vraiment le mil
d'action didio l'eau alors nous on est
convaincu que c'est un gisement énorme
et qui demande à être être exploitées de
manière très systématique
l'une des difficultés qui à l'exploiter
c'est que c'est un travail de fourmi qui
se fait sur le terrain localement en
liaison avec les clients les industriels
les collectivités locales
mais on a de très beaux exemples la cité
j'ai sous les yeux l'exemple de l'usiné
yoplait de vienne dans l'isère qu'on a
dont on récupère la chaleur fatale qu'on
utilise à la fois pour chauffer une
école de la ville et 7 191 logements
sociaux ce faisant on a fait une
économie de co2 de plus de 50% sur la
consommation énergétique de ses de ses
bâtiments et des histoires comme ça
quand on interroge notre activité angie
solution on en a des milliers à raconter
les petits ruisseaux font les grandes
rivières et nous sommes convaincus que
si on exploite ou ses gisements chaleur
fatale géothermie y compris la
géothermie basse température le stockage
de chaleur dans le sol qui permet de
récupérer la chaleur en hiver et de la
stocker en été toutes ces technologies
permettent des économies qui se qui se
chiffrent en dizaines de cars à water à
l'échelle de la france mais c'est un
travail de fourmi de les collecter dans
l'est les mettre en oeuvre et en
particulier c'est un travail qui reste
très difficile à valoriser tant qu'on
n'a pas un prix du carbone qui permet de
rendre ces technologies
visiblement rentables c'est à dire de
faire payer ou de rémunérer les
externalités positives ou de faire payer
les externalités négatives
oui et mais en même temps c'est
politiquement pas forcément très payant
parce que c'est pas c'est pas facilement
visible à moins d'avoir des indicateurs
de macroéconomie de sobriété énergétique
ça fait pas rêver c'est très visible
pour les collectivités je suis sûr que
le maire de vienne que je ne connais pas
personnellement à valoriser auprès de
ses administrés le fait que 7 191
logements sociaux elle être chauffée
avec la chaleur fatale de nézignan plaît
je suis certain que si vous voulez ces
solutions
enfin le maire de pau qui se trouve
aussi être le commissaire au plan était
très heureux d'inaugurer la station de
bus à hydrogène qu'on a installé
sur sa commune et qui au passage
produits l'hydrogène par électrolyse
d'électricité verte donc ça n'est pas
émetteurs de co2 pour pour le cas
présent
donc ça de la visibilité locale mais
c'est une des grosses difficultés du
chapitre de la sobriété c'est que les
résultats sont atteints par des millions
de décisions microscopique
microéconomiques et que on a du mal à
lui donner deux à donner de la
visibilité aux systèmes sont marche dans
ce que j'explique à mes étudiants quand
on parle d'économie d'énergie je leur
dis qu'il ya trois types d'économie
d'énergie et je vais essayer de l'aider
filière l'enjeu toute petite lisa sion
avant un des problèmes qui empoisonnent
le débat sur la question climatique et
sur la question environnementale c'est
qu'on passe son temps à manipuler des
concepts qui n'ont pas de contenu
dramatique par exemple faire ça n'a pas
compris normatif moi je sais pas ce que
c'est que d'électricité verte
je sais ce que c'est que le contenu
carbone en électricité je sais combien
de mètres carrés au sol on a utilisé
pour produire un kilo watt heure je sais
éventuellement combien de chauves-souris
en 28 éoliennes puis s'agissait et
qu'est ce qui est vert de même que la
notion de durable est ce que ça va être
dur à huit semaines milan 152 on passe
le temps à tourner à utiliser des
contenus et herman normatif c'était ça
que pourquoi j'ai essayé de donner un
contenu normatif aux écoles et il ya
trois sous-ensembles la première sous
catégorie est ce qu on appelle ce que
moi j'appelle l'efficacité énergétique
en efficacité énergétique c'est je garde
le même niveau de service
je conduis une voiture de la même taille
de la même puissance de la même masse
alors la vitesse et c'est juste ça
consomme moins alors ça ça c'est que du
bonheur
parce que la charge de l'effort n'est
pas sur le consommateur mais sur les
ingénieurs de chez toujours au coût de
chennegy kick ass revue les fesses et
par ailleurs c'est quelque chose qui
permet à approvisionnements énergétiques
données d'augmenter la quantité de
services dans le pib
donc c'est pas du tout incompatible avec
la croissance donc celle là c'est que du
bonheur et les politiques l'adorent
qu'après les médecins après il ya un
deuxième mode d'économie d'énergie c'est
je me prive délibérément du service donc
je passe de la voiture ont fait ou
voiture un vélo ce n'est pas une voiture
alors il ya une partie des
fonctionnalités que ça rassure ça dure
et aujourd'hui je suis allée au travail
en vélo ça a déplacé la carcasse la
preuve
mais ça n'a pas exactement les mêmes
services j'ai pas d'autoradio j'ai moins
protégés en cas d'accident ça aussi des
avantages
tiens ma carcasse mais c'est pas la même
chose ça coûte moins cher par ailleurs
si j'avais une voiture quand j'en ai pas
si j'avais une voiture pour aller au
travail
aller en vélo me coûte moins cher donc
j'abandonne délibérément un service
parce que du coup j'abandonne
délibérément la consommation d'énergie
qui part avec ça ça s'appelle la
sobriété
il ya un troisième mode d'économie
d'énergie qui s'appelle la pauvreté en
la pauvreté c'est la même chose que la
sobriété sauf que j'ai rien demandé
j'abandonne le service parce que j'ai pu
les moyens de lui offrir j'abandonne le
service parce que un événement extérieur
indépendant de ma volonté me l'a imposé
gilet jaune à l'autre le seul truc qui
se gère pas confortablement dans un
monde pacifié
c'est la pauvreté pendant la pauvreté
les gens en général n'aiment pas trop ça
donc on a le choix dossier entre la
sobriété et l'efficacité énergétique
stricto sensu est en fait tout le monde
adore comme je les ai pas leur
l'efficacité énergétique qui n'impose
aucune charge pour ces amateurs
et qui impose toutes les charges aux
concepteurs du problème c'est pour ça
que les politiques a dans sa sobriété il
n'aime pas ça récessif
je me prive du service donc la société
par ailleurs ou à disparaître si on
arrête de faire des voitures parce que
les gens roulent à vélo c'est récessif
prix actuels des voitures sauf si on se
met à dépenser l'argent qu'on dépense
est plus dans la fabrication de voitures
dans la fabrication d'infrastructures
pour rouler à vélo arrive ça cycliste
auquel cas il payera la même chose
qu'avant mais pour trouver avec le haut
il ya un sujet si l'on de récession je
le redis historiquement on a travaillé
l'efficacité autant qu'on a voulu et sur
à peu près tout ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui on est plus efficace les
octets là qu'on est en train d'échanger
en se rangeant derrière un ordinateur
transporter de manière beaucoup plus
efficace que dans le premier ordinateur
mangal qui avait 18 villes tu la victime
et maryvonne le 150 kilowatts de
puissance
la voiture dans laquelle je monte de
temps en temps en défendant est beaucoup
plus efficace par kilo par kilos
transporté par un cheval de puissance
sauf que malheureusement ça n'a jamais
suffi à modérer la consommation globale
d'énergie qui est la seule chose qui
compte pour la perturbation
environnementale puisque la planète fait
désespérément 13 8 km en permanence
premiers kilomètres de dire être en
permanence donc ce qui compte c'est la
valeur absolue de la perturbation a mené
par les hommes et donc la bonne question
c'est est-ce que d'efficacité technique
sol est à la hauteur du problème la
réponse est non cela fait un siècle et
demi qu'on en fait si d'énergétique et
d'efficacité technique et ça fait un
siècle et demi que l'approvisionnement
énergétique augmente les émissions
augmentent les espèces disparaissent
manifestement ça suffit pas et en fait
si on veut réussir la transition deux
degrés on n'y arrivera pas sans marié à
la fois de la sobriété qui récessive et
de l'efficacité qui est là où ça va
devenir particulièrement sportif et ça
me permet de regonfler aussi sur ce qui
a été dit tout à l'heure sur les coûts
la raison pour laquelle les couples
éoliens d'une bd alors ils trouvent que
c'est des coups de l'éolien et du
téléthon qu'on a parlé mais ce que je
pourrais dire c'est en fait à tous les
goûts
raison pour laquelle des coûts diminuent
c'est parce que la quantité de travail
et de rentes humain parce qu'on ne paye
que des hommes avec l'argent contenu
dans un objet diminue au cours du temps
c'est ça que ça veut dire que les coûts
diminuent d'accord donc les coûts ne
contiennent pas la totalité de
l'information sur l'objet physique c'est
juste une information que ça nous donne
c'est la quantité de rentrer et de
travail humain qui est incluse dans le
produit fini ventes ont fini par
disposer comme les ressources naturelles
vallaurien par convention et que
l'énergie ne vaut rien par convention
tant qu'elle est dans l'environnement
plus on mécanise et plus on a un travail
qui devient productivité avec beaucoup
de machines adjointe à des gens et plus
les coûts baissent
est ce qu'on a vu historiquement au
cannet aux liens pas cher et un
photovoltaïque pas cher c'est
essentiellement un éolien ar
photovoltaïque produit par une société
dopé aux combustibles fossiles
si demain matin il fallait faire en
france avec le cuivre en france le
germanium français le fer français
l'aluminium france etc
des panneaux solaires du silicium en 6 g
et laure français et l'argent français
et ces métropolitains les éoliennes et
les panneaux solaires eux mêmes est
fabriqué avec des éoliennes et les
panneaux solaires uniquement et compris
la métallurgie amant est lâché diamants
je ne suis pas complètement convaincu
que ça resterait au prix actuel
donc on a un sujet l'asservissement
globale du système il faut jamais
oublier quand on regarde les coûts et on
passe notre temps à passer du marginal
au moyen des gens ça comptera aucun
problème
pas sûr donc l'efficacité technique seul
ça marchera pas marcher jusqu'à
maintenant il faut marier ça avec une
contrainte accepté qui consiste à se
limiter sur les usages et ça posera un
énorme poids et les conneries qu'est ce
que ça soit réceptif
je vais dire d'une autre manière le
scénario 2 degrés dans un contexte de
croissance économique
je n'y crois tellement pas une seconde
que je suis prêt à nouveau à paris avec
qui et quand on regarde les sorte de
grandeur se rencontrer je dis pas ça
donnait dès que je peux en dire lupi
vive la récession juste en train de dire
penser que l'on peut combiner les deux
ça marche pas et par ailleurs penser
qu'on va échapper à la récession
une planète de 13me km de diamètre n'y
crois pas non plus je crois qu'à un
moment on va rentrer dans une
compression structurelle de l'économie
parce que tous les travaux ou de
physiciens que j'ai vu qu'ils portaient
sur ce genre d' approche systémique
convergent la conclusion l'économie
n'est rien d'autre qu'une représentation
conventionnelle avec des euros des flux
physiques qui sous-tendent d'activités
productives des dom et ses flux
physiques non seulement ils peuvent pas
croître christ au ciel
et quand ils sont issus de ressources
non renouvelables les théorèmes de maya
deren de matt rusch encore démontré
disent que ça nous impose que il y aura
un maximum à jour et une décroissance
structurelle derrière donc le la
sobriété
je suis insisté là dessus est absolument
indispensable et en fait aujourd'hui le
problème c'est pas de savoir comment on
va éviter la récession c'est de savoir
comment on va éviter de dynamiter les
sociétés humaines dans un contexte dans
lequel de toute façon pas sa crainte est
un tout petit peu différent dans le
cahier des charges est dans ce monde là
pour finir le progrès technique
diffusera moins vite parce que le
progrès technique est aujourd'hui
assurée par la rotation du capital et
dans un monde en contraction économique
la rotation du capital sera
considérablement ralenti donc l'idée
qu'on va diffuser du progrès
technologique dans un monde en
contraction économique est une idée à
laquelle je souscris pas sur facture en
tout cas c'est pas aussi simple que ça
et je pense qu'on a un problème interne
n'a pas réfléchi collectivement je la
mets dedans qui est comment assurer la
diffusion du progrès technique dans un
monde dans lequel les fluides augmentent
plus que se contracte parce que je pense
que là il ya sérieuses limites
les gens vont faire durer leur actif un
bon je sais pas si tyloo de répondre on
pouvait assez le gym quelques mois et en
face au débat oui je pense qu'une façon
de piloter leur tour une trajectoire de
degré et de le piloter avec une certaine
fille
sc un prix du carbone on a beau dire que
tout - card encore en discuter que les
progrès technologiques qui ont été faits
je suis désolé mais si on mettait 100
euros de la tonne de carbone ou même
s'il est en faisait ce qu'a dit le
rapport quinet c'est à dire prenez 250
euros la tonne de carbone pour décider
de ses politiques publiques
on ferait des choix extrêmement
différent donc peut-être certaines
conséquences seraient récessive
ponctuellement mais qui conduirait à
découvrir des gisements de productivité
dans certains cas de sobriété qui sont
aujourd'hui complètement inexploité
gérard et que c'est si on parle de
sobriété le fait aujourd'hui de proposer
des vélos à assistance électrique change
le choix voiture contre vélo et donc de
ce point de vue là c'est il illustre
bien le fait que le progrès permet aussi
de gagner sur la sobriété
oui mais comme je le redis c'est aussi
un mouvement qui reste fixé sur le prix
du carbone jean-marc alors j'ai écrit
déclaration d'amour à la taxe carbone en
2006 avec mon associé actuelle le ram
les associés actuels s'appelle alain
grandjean donc on a fait les choses dans
les formes puisqu'on a fait carbone cac
après avoir fait de fiançailles qui
consistait à écrire un bouquin en commun
et le je suis un peu revenu là dessus
depuis cette époque alors je ne suis pas
complètement revenus c'est à dire je
pense que le signal prix est utile dans
un certain nombre de cas de figure par
contre je pense que ce n'est pas du tout
un outil universel et je veux dire
pourquoi la première raison c'est que
quand on regarde quel est le coût à la
tonne de co2 évitée entente calcul pour
un certain nombre de transition par
exemple passer de la voiture à pétrole
la loi car électrique en france on
arrive très vite à des coups à la tonne
de co2 évitée qui tape les quelques
centaines les quelques milliers d'euros
donc je pense que l'acceptation du corps
social pour entendre des montants de cet
ordre là
du temps de mon vivant je ne verrai
jamais ça la deuxième raison pour
laquelle je pense qu'il faut un peu
revenir dessus c'est qu'il ya appris
qu'il ya un marché
or le marché est par construction un
instrument pas du tout adapté au
pilotage du long terme marché et d'un
instrument d'optimisation de court terme
d'un cadre structurant qui ne peut pas
être décidé par le marché donc le reste
on l'a bien vu l'ouverture à la entre
guillemets concurrence de l'électricité
en europe
on cherche encore la liste des effets
bénéfiques que c'est un produit qu'on a
essentiellement mis un des peines voile
de brouillard sur votre capacité à
piloter de long terme et c'est à peu
près tout ce qu'on a réussi à faire
caudry cendres autant j'aurais alors là
je vais me faire plaisir autant j'aurais
été tout à fait favorables au fait qu'on
dise on fait un bolide aux vols
réguliers par l'état vous en avez marre
des fl et boire une vie dont près de la
moitié des centrales nucléaires on se
sent très bien
veolia suez non mais très honnêtement
les un enfant du poids de ribaud main
très bien aller voir l'autre mais on a
des acteurs qui ont la surface pour
piloter des investissements qui sont à
la mesure du problème
mais la concurrence à laval en disant
que dans les mares ddf aller voir direct
energie et les normes communes c'est
juste un transfert des recettes
publiques les adhérents de prier sans
aucun investissement bénéfique pour la
collectivité en face ça n'a servi à rien
sinon à permettre tant donc le marché
n'étant pas un instrument de pilotage de
lanternes
il ya un certain nombre de transition
qui sont beaucoup plus efficaces quand
elles sont décidées par voie
réglementaire que quand elles sont des
idées parfois des je vais prendre un
exemple du conte qui est bâtiment je ne
pense pas que conduira les propriétaires
à planifier correctement à l'isolation
de leurs bâtiments en remontant prix du
gaz par contre je suis totalement
persuadé que si on dit à des gens je
vous préviens que dans dix ans j'aurais
pu voir une chaudière fioul chez vous ça
c'est quelque chose qui s'organise
c'est un signal réglementaire c'est un
signal prix exactement dans le même état
d'esprit
la voie réglementaire qui consiste à
dire non mais t'es pas une voiture sur
le marché et qui concerne plus de temps
c'est également une voie réglementaire
qui est potentiellement capable d'aller
beaucoup plus vite que le circuit et qui
n'a plus socialement beaucoup plus
facile à entendre
donc je suis donc un signal prix ça ne
marche que si un marché si ya pas de
marché si la régulation se fait hors
marché par voie réglementaire par vote
rationnement le signal prix n'a même
plus de raison d'être
en tant que instrument qui permet de
dire là où la nuisance et enfin il ya un
dernier point sur lequel je voudrais
attirer l'attention des gens qui nous
écoutent
c'est que à partir du moment où on dit
la taxe carbone est un outil dissuasif
il faut être sûr que ça ne deviendra
jamais un impôt de rendement et donc il
faut être sûr que l'état d'entrée de jeu
organismes correctement la disparition
future de l'assiette est là l'expérience
montre que malheureusement l'état un
tout petit peu de mal à faire ce genre
de choses
donc c'est un gros problème aussi avec
la taxe carbone qui est que c'est un
instrument ou à manipuler avec
précaution ça on l'avait dit dans le
bain s'il vous plaît l'inde et 2006 on
avait dit ajoutant c'est un instrument
qui doit être organisée en n'oubliant
pas qu'il est censé provoquer de lui
même la disparition de son assiette
hartung à ça et je pense que le petit
sourire en coin fait qu'on partage la
boutique méfiance qu'on peut avoir pour
la puissance publique dès qu'elle met la
main sur une recette budgétaire pour
st-pascal donc le voilà donc c'est pour
ça que je pense que cet instrument il
est vraiment à manipuler avec précaution
et qu'il ya beaucoup de cas de figure
dans lequel la voie réglementaire
considérablement toussaint
considérablement plus efficace bon on
peut peut-être passer à la partie des
bas donc il y avait plus de 300
participants qui ont posé plus beau plus
d'une trentaine de questions j'ai pas pu
suivre mais christophe des a pu
superviser toutes ces rma on pourra
faire deux choses il pourra prendre
quelques questions ou encire bêtisier
quelques-unes et éventuellement passer
la parole à quelques personnes dans
l'instant la salle qu'on pourra
transformer en conférencier pour
l'occasion grâce à l'intervention de
l'évent maintien
christophe oui alors m'entendais bien
non si mais pas tout ce qu'on entend
mais il faut monter volume et ben je
vais parler plus fort possible
alors bon sélections sauf nucléaire
énormément de questions j'en ai dit une
il y avait une question sur le prix de
theix cap en gros taxe carbone donc je
pense que les questions des réponses que
vous avez apporté là me permettent de
supprimer la question si la personne
n'est pas contente elle réutilise la
boîte et elle précise sur le nucléaire
vu une bonne dizaine de questions je
vais en résumé quelques unes et puis je
avoir un certain jeu 4-3-3 question un
peu sur sur les risques et on va dire
évidemment que vous imaginez bien une
sur l'acceptabilité je devais la résumer
comme ça une autre sur la sûreté est ce
qu'on peut ne pas parler de la sûreté
donc évacuer le problème comme ça mais
c'est une question
et puis l'autre qui est à l'évidence
c'est pas possible dans tous les pays et
notamment il faut forcément des états un
peu fort et donc de deux états avec
correction on imagine bien que je dois
pas être possible tout c'est pour
résumer trois premières questions sur le
nucléaire par me dise si vous voulez
réagir
kishi qui distribue la parole partie
histoire très très rapidement si je
prends l'initiative dont la sûreté on va
pas débattre aujourd'hui de la sûreté
nucléaire on la prend comme un
pré-requis ce qui veut dire
effectivement qu'on peut pas faire du
nucléaire dans n'importe quel pays
deuxièmement
sur l'acceptabilité là aussi c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles on prend pas
le faire dans n'importe quel pays sauf à
passer en économie de guerre comme le
disait jean marc jancovici
mais moi il ya un point que je voudrais
souligner parce qu'on le suit 1 cc ce
que j'ai appelé la disponibilité
systémique dire que le problème du
nucléaire c'est que pour être efficace
et pour être sûr vous développer un
modèle et vous le dupliquer ce qui veut
dire que le jour où vous avez un
problème générique vous êtes s'il est un
peu gras vous êtes tenu d'arrêter toutes
vos tranches en même temps les ça ça
pose un problème de disponibilité
deuxième problème de disponibilité la
sensibilité du nucléaire à la canicule
le jour où le niveau de toutes les
rivières baisse parce que vous êtes en
période de canicule
vous arrêtez vos tranches les unes après
les autres et et c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles je pense qu'il n'est pas
raisonnable de rester à 70 sont 80%
nucléaire et je pense que baisser un peu
est tout à fait raisonnable dans un mix
équilibré alors remplacer par quoi bein
je pense je pense que là il faut du il
faut des renouvelables et du stockage
avec que ce soit du biométhane ou 10
août l'hydrogène mais il faut une
solution stockables qui permette d'avoir
de l'énergie quand on en a besoin parce
qu'on la stocker alors ils passent aux
frais 5 6 après ça ça fonctionne pas
toute l'année ça si on a stockées sont
si on a stocké son hydrogène dans des
cavités salines argent' dont on peut
faire un rapide calcul de revendeur le
rendement électricité l'électricité en
passant par l'hydrogène des lampes de
25% un peu plus que ça mais ouais enfin
sur le papier donc le
dans la vraie vie c'est toujours un peu
moins bien que sur les papiers et ça
veut dire que si on veut suppléa
quelques tranches nucléaires pendant
l'été ça veut dire qu'on est en train de
parler les 20-30 cas radiateur
d'électricité à ce moment il faut en
avoir qu'on fournisse en vain pour faire
l'hydrogène ou etc
on parle plus de cacahuètes je suis pas
complètement sûr que voilà autant l'idée
d'avoir à tout petit peu de solutions de
stockage je sais trop quelle manière à
discuter peut se justifier les par
ailleurs y'a pas que construire plus de
centrales nucléaires en bord de mer
il n'y a pas de dans les délais qui sont
partis là on demain matin quand même pas
au stade où les centrales vont devoir
s'arrêter de fonctionner pendant tous
les mois d'été par manque de
refroidissement sur moi je le jure il ya
sur l'acceptabilité et la sûreté
quelques éléments de réponse le premier
edition et le fait qu'on peut pas en
faire partie alors j'avais fait un jour
un petit calcul montrant que 90% des
centrales à charbon installés dans le
monde le sont dans des pays qui maîtrise
déjà la tourbe 90 % du parc de centrales
à charbon dans le monde se trouvent dans
des pays
par ailleurs les pays disposent de
centrales nucléaires une autorité sur
qui me suit si j'ai fait le calcul
la chine l'inde le japon l'allemagne les
etats-unis la france et c'est enfin la
france au charbon tous ces pays la bible
c'était quand je fais le calcul est égal
de trois ans dans les états unis c'est
peut-être un peu moins c'était 90 % du
parc de centrales à charbon dans le
monde à commencer par la chine comme
j'avais dit qu'il fait là le deuxième
élément c'est que
la sûreté aujourd'hui il ya deux
manières de répondre à la question une
première manière qui est de dire
regardez ce qui se passe au pire quand
ça décolle vraiment et regardez les
inconvénients quand ça déconne vraiment
comparer avec d'autres inconvénients ça
déconne vraiment la voiture tu tous les
ans trois millions de personnes dans le
monde
est-ce que vous avez sortir de la
voiture les barrages ont plus tué en
europe que les centrales nucléaires
vous avez sortir des barrages je ne
crois pas la chimie a considérablement
plus tu es dans le monde que le
nucléaire les égouts qui ont explosé
dans quelle ville du mexique là ont fait
400 morts
un seul coup est ce que vous allez
sortir des égouts ge ses escaliers et
les électrocutions les gens qui
s'étouffe chez eux tu vingt huit
personnes par an en france que vous
allez sortir des maisons etc sinon les
pis il tue tête le centaine de personnes
tous les ans avant des gamins parce que
vous avez sortir des piscines et enfin
de charbon ra dickey ken les de la
surface de la terre
rien que chez les videurs de charbon
rien que chez les mineurs de charbon
l'équivalent de la ville de grenoble en
cause des suites des maladies
professionnelles les mineurs de charbon
se [ __ ] des pas de poussière dans les
poumons pendant qu'il mines de charbon
on a amplement connu ça en france enfin
je les répare les années 70 et 80
dans l'accord de les anciens mineurs ils
ont mouillé le charbon donc si on remet
les inconvénients en perspective moi je
ne vois pas de raison encore une fois de
renoncer à quelque chose qui par
ailleurs est une marge de manoeuvre pour
éviter des famines d'abord des coraux
les enfants et les millions de réfugiés
qui leur est partout ça évitera pas tout
mais tout ce que ça peut amener comme
contribution à ça dans les autres
inconvénients qu'on avait dit qu'on est
con et graines souvent et 1 1 qui
consiste donc pour le moment la sûreté à
les gérer en france s'en sorte pas
toujours le cas enfin pour moins de
j'irai dans les autres inconvénients il
y en a deux qui sont souvent mentionné
qu'ils sont
les déchets et l'autriche est générale
sur les déchets je vais rappeler
déterminant physique c'est que l'énergie
nucléaire est de l'ordre sur un atom
donné 200 millions de fois plus
puissante que l'énergie chimique dire
quand vous avez une transition
électronique sur un atom qui correspond
à l'énergie chimique
on est en jeu une énergie de quelques
électrons volts quand vous avez une
fission de noyaux d'uranium en met en
jeu une énergique 200 millions
d'électron volts
ce qui veut dire que hamas égal parce
que tout fonctionne pas mais hamas égal
il faut un gramme à énergie égale fois
un gramme d'uranium pour fournir
l'énergie de combustion d'une tonne de
pétrole donc l'énergie nucléaire
consiste à manipuler des quantités qui
sont toutes petites de matière on fait
des déchets qui seront des vrais merle
mais en toute petite quantité faut bien
il faut bien d'avoir ça en fait la
totalité des déchets nucléaires du parc
français et tient dans un gymnase
depuis quarante ans d'exploitation c'est
tout petit il ya des tas de trucs qu'on
laisse partir
et dans le même temps on bazarde 50
pilotes de phytosanitaires dans
l'environnement tous les angles pour que
les déchets et c'est pas pour moi ont
raison d'y renoncer
c'est tout petit encore une fois si vous
mettez ça à 450 m sous terre dans une
couche géologique n'a pas bougé depuis
cent millions d'années
en réalité que cela nous ressortent à la
figure en tête des bus ont pour tuer
tout le monde paraît pas très élevé donc
que l'acceptabilité ce travail à mon
avis pour moi par la pédagogie et à ne
se travaille pas par un autre moyen
c'était aujourd'hui c'est ce que j'étais
tout à l'heure il ya énormément de gens
qui ont juste ils savent pas ce que
c'est il ya un sondage qui vient d'être
fait par l'association canadienne du
nucléaire qui a montré que quand on
demandait à la population ce qu'ils
avaient un avis en leur précisant dans
les réponses qu'il y avait droit de
cocher j'ai pas je n'ai pas suffisamment
bien compris de sujets pour avoir un
avis il ya la moitié des femmes qui
répondent un an les offres sont très
présentes tuerie avec un quart mais à
mon avis il surprend beaucoup mieux ils
sont plus fiers
mais il ya la moitié des femmes qui
répondent ça donc je pense qu'une bonne
partie des gens sont pas notés entre des
trucs contradictoires et premier la
première chose à faire pour sortir de là
c'est de faire de la pédagogie correct
pour dix ans ça c'est un vrai
inconvénient s'en séparer en veillant ou
plus exactement si vous mettez ça en
perspective avec autre chose
le premier c'est pas la première raison
d'y renoncer sur la standardisation au
finir là-dessus on peut très bien
diversifier les filières nucléaires
on n'est pas obligé d'avoir cinquante
fois mes modèles de réacteurs moi je
suis parfaitement favorable parce qu on
est cinq fois dix réacteurs
ça me servirait très bien pour dire ce
que tu disais tout à l'heure j'ai juste
un petit commentaire je vois que
quelques personnes utilisent la fonction
sympa lever la main le problème c'est
que comme il ya 37 30 questions on
attend tous beaucoup de monde on levant
la main je risque de ne pas vous donner
la parole
il n'y a plus de chance de la voir si
vous résumer votre question christophe
tél alors j'ai trois questions qui sont
autant de précision toujours sans
nucléaire
une personne qui dit le coût de
construction
apparemment élevé mais n'est-il pas dû
au fait qu on arrêter de construire des
centrales pendant 15 ans une question de
précision sur quelles sont les réserves
de combustibles sont nucléaire et une
troisième sur combien de temps peut-on
raisonnablement allongé l'exploitation
nucléaire un coup décembre didier on va
laisser le temps de répondre à trois
questions
il y en a deux sur lesquels
pour répondre un peu nous s'agissant de
la question du coût du nucléaire neuf
mois je constate que tous les gens
auxquels je parle dans cette industrie
n'ont pas d'espoir de nous faire un
réacteur moderne à moins de 80 euros le
mégawattheure à quel coût du capital
dans les conditions qu'ils ont en france
d'accord notamment donc dont 80 euros le
mégawattheure nous notre conviction
c'est que c'est plus cher au terme dont
on parle c'est à dire dans dix ans que
des solutions renouvelables
intermittentes les stockages et c'est
nettement plus cher que des solutions du
type biogaz par exemple pour les usages
d'un deuxième point sur combien on peut
prolonger
ben aujourd'hui nous sommes en
discussion avec le gouvernement belge
pour prolonger au delà de 2025 pour pour
10 15 ou 20 ans les tranches nucléaires
belges qui sont en bon état de
fonctionnement et donc c'est la base sur
laquelle on discute
est ce qu'il faudra les prolonger bien
au delà ça dépendra du gouvernement
belge ça dépendra de l'état dans lequel
se elles seront à ce moment là mais pour
l'instant nous considérons que entre 10
et 20 ans de prolongation
problème alors sur la question de la
prolongation je voudrais alors la
philosophie de la sûreté est pas le même
aux états unis qu'en france c'est parce
qu'elle est en belgique si c'est le
state of diatou cissé dans l'état
initial de construction mais je sais
qu'en france où c'est stévia c'est à
dire c'est très différente aux états
unis mais aux états unis votre centrale
elle doit toujours être dans l'état dans
lequel ne l'avait construite c'est pas
mieux que ça comble dans cette sous ces
conditions là tous les opérateurs
américains ont demandé de passage à 60
ans et un certain nombre commence à
demander le passage à 80 donc la
question de la prolongation pour moi est
une question qui est beaucoup plus en
dire beaucoup moins triviale que
c'était conçu pour 40 ans s'arrête à 40
ans les bons termes du débat la
prolongation des réacteurs existants et
de toute façon la solution la plus
économique puisque le nucléaire tout est
dans le nom de construction versus toute
autre alternative
dès lors que l'on a la possibilité de
prolonger moi j'ai la possibilité c'est
la possibilité technique d'acceptation
etc dès lors qu'on a la possibilité pour
longer aériennes - j'ai donc ça veut
dire que dans le même temps on peut
utiliser notre argent si on n'a pas
besoin de le mettre dans la construction
de nouveaux moyens quel qu'il soit pour
faire des pistes cyclables effectivement
du biogaz et pertinents sauver les
baraques
on met nos moyens ailleurs ce qui dans
une course contre la montre est
extrêmement impressionné le sur la
question pardon il y avait une question
sur les tueries et les dix autres c'est
lé quotidien sur il avait une question
donc sur le coup est ce que c'est pas
parce qu'on ne s'est arrêté 2,6 alors si
c'est évident ça quand vous regardez les
chinois ils ont construit les opérateurs
chan qui sont copines rowling puisqu'ils
sont en service commercial aujourd'hui
ils sont terminées sauf erreur de ma
part pour 4 ou 5 milliards d'euros pièce
donc les chinois ils mettent en service
rim est en construction six réacteurs
par an évidemment il ya un effet de
serre y est tu restes il nous est arrivé
une déconvenue en finlande puisqu'on a
aussi un le p r en construction à
olkiluoto
des finlandais dino nucléaire on adore
ça donc on va commander un deuxième
réacteur comme vous les français vous
êtes des incapables
comment des arts cet homme ce qui s'est
passé enfin les coréens ont construit
des réacteurs qui vont services services
aux émirats arabes unis qui sont des
réacteurs de l'agréable 4 gigawatts
c'est un peu moins que le p r enfin pas
beaucoup moins et ils sont terminées
pour 6 milliards de dollars pièce donc
on n'a pas une français sur le nucléaire
c'est très clair en plus de tout le
reste
sur le coup à 80 euros le mégawattheure
je le redis
quand on prend un coût de construction à
4 à 4,5 milliards d'euros
hawat avec un coût du capital
raisonnable et un peu de capital
raisonnable ne peut s'envisager que dans
le cadre où la filière est piloté par
l'état
j'insiste s'est confié à un opérateur
privé qui vient d'étriller à ses risques
et périls
c'est juste impossible d'arriver on est
en dessous de 80 je le redis avec le
père jean paul qui est trop cher je suis
d'accord avec l'autre c'est trop
compliqué le dr et bien on arrive à
descendre en dessous de 50
si on a un coût du capital raisonnable
qu'est ce que j'appelle un coût du
capital raisonnable
c'est dans un univers dans lequel il n'y
a pas de risque politique sur la durée
d'exploitation comme le coût est
totalement lié à la construction s'il ya
un risque politique sur la durée
d'exploitation évidemment ça fait
exploser le coût du capital
c'est à dire que l'état donné sa
garantie sur le fait que si on va pas
jusqu'au terme des dommages d'opérateur
pour la partie qui n'aura pas été qui
n'aura pas eu lieu c'est une
expropriation et à ce moment on
dédommage exactement comme ça s'est
passé à fessenheim qui va coûter bonbon
de ce point de vue au pays eh bien
dans un monde dans lequel les dos
aujourd'hui sont négatifs moi je
considère que si on sert un investisseur
auquel 40e' un rendement sur 60 ans si
on lui sert 2% il est très bien servi
très bien je suis pris avec mon
assurance vie là-dedans donc c'est ça
que je donne comme ordre de grandeur et
à ce moment on peut descendre à des
coûts qui sont un sérieux après je le
redis si je revenais toujours besoin
défendeurs aujourd'hui vous avez un
facteur 1000 milles d'occupation des
espaces entre le nucléaire et le solaire
à production identique en france donc on
est allé clairement français du solaire
à la fin de l'année quand il est alors
la même quantité d'électricité
ça ne peut enfin ça ne savait pas
répéter dans le coup tant qu'on
considère que l'espace disponible au sol
vaut rien si on considère que l'espace
disponible au sol vous très chers parce
qu'on a envie de préserver la
biodiversité liger des cultures ou chez
par quoi ça change totalement l'équation
donc le coup je veux insister sur un
point les parages ne contient pas toute
l'information sur la disponibilité ou la
pertinence futur c'est le goût ne
contient que la quantité de travail
humain qui à l'instant t
et la quantité de rente humaine qui à
l'instant t est inclus dans ce don pour
bénéficient c'est juste ça le coup c'est
déjà pas mal mais c'est juste que ça il
ya énormément de questions c'est ça
empire
on ferme à quelle heure
dans le cip 19ème mois pouvant dépasser
un petit peu mais pas trop parce qu'il
faut que je rentre chez moi et j'en ai
jamais pour plus de 10 du team il y
avait une question de précision sur les
réserves aux combustibles
mais après soit très rapide si la
plainte est si ça j'ai déjà répondu tout
à l'heure le cabaret c'est qu'il y en a
pas assez pour faire du nucléaire en
déterminant principal de la suppression
du charbon sur des siècles
ok donc il faut passer à l'exploitation
de l'uranium 238 auditorium il ya une
question sur la répartition des
centrales nucléaires en chine qui
apparemment sans doute près de la mer et
si effectivement il faut monter à 30% ce
serait sans doute un peu plus haut au
milieu des terres
je ne sais pas si vous avez un avis là
dessus je vois pas pourquoi ça serait
plus compliqué le transporter de
l'électricité sûr trois mille kilomètres
en chine à partir de la côte que la
transporter sur 3000 km à partir du
désir de sarah tout un pack anti
nucléaire veut mettre des panneaux
solaires pense que c'est dit plus ou
moins compliquées
il n'est pas certain que ce soit que sur
le problème du transport que la question
se posait mais je lui mette à prêter
plus peut-être on peut passer la parole
à patrick pélata qui à deux chiffres
l'unss au nucléaire l'autre sur
l'hydrogène peut être deux pour a
expliqué ces questions lunebourg didier
hollow et l'autre bon jean marc
jancovici
et où paul il passait la parole si ça
marche sinon je c'est vrai alors est ce
qu'elles vivent and managers peuvent
peut rendre à patrick pélata orateurs
4 1
alors normalement je lui je lui ai
laissé la possibilité de parler il doit
se reconnecter en tant que conférencier
là ça va être compliqué disent que ceux
autorisés peut-être qu'on peut on peut
le lire sa question réussite et les deux
mémoires faut que je la retrouve ici t1
une étude du mighty qui avait plutôt
dans le sens de jean marc jancovici
si je les bienvenus c'est terrible trou
badri tu as loire le voilà tu arrives
for me tiens tu mettes un micro
ça y est vas-y constat question c'est
bon ah oui sur le nom sur le nucléaire
versus les une étude excellente du
myhtique sur le potentiel du nucléaire
pour réduire sabir apprenant les
objectifs de réduction de terrebonne à 0
en 2005 quand ça c'est un degré 5 à 0 en
2070 c'est les 2 degrés et effectivement
ce qu'il dit c'est que pour le texas
pour le maroc pour le sud de la
californie on peut travailler avec le
solaire et avec l'éolien pour la chine
continentale pour l'essentiel de la
chine en fait ça marche pas c'est à dire
qu'on ne fait pas le lien et en a beau
on a beau y mettre du stockage ça suffit
pas il ya les quantités nécessaires
d'énergie pour alimenter la chine est de
loin et donc ce qu'ils disent c'est que
pour pour le nord des états unis pour
une grande partie de l'europe et pour le
la chine
le nucléaire est incontournable si on
veut si on veut vraiment arriver à zéro
en électricité en train de carbone de
l'électricité comme ça je pense que
c'est un point qui est un document qui
est pas connue en france c'est bizarre
il n'a pas eu d'écho dans les médias
alors que pour moi il est fondamental
parce qu'il est extrêmement détaillées
sur une cartographie de l'énergie qu'on
peut attendre du solaire et de l'éolien
par grandes régions du nil
ça c'est le premier point de deuxième
point pour l'idéologie et et j'ai réagi
sur les douces à hydrogène parce que le
rendement ça a été dit tout à l'heure
moi j'utilise des valeurs plus optimiste
que celle de jancovici
c'est à dire le rendement électricité
via electronista hydrogène et
électricité à nouveau dans un moteur
dans une voiture dans un bus dans un
camion on veut c entre 25 et 30% et donc
ça veut dire que le aujourd'hui c'est
indéfendable de faire ça alors que le
rendement par une batterie
il est 2 en passant par une batterie il
est de l'heure
de 90% ce qui veut dire que en stockage
pour la mobilité les batteries c'est
beaucoup mieux
avant on disait il ya des problèmes
d'autonomie mais aujourd'hui une toyota
et une tesla 3 ça la même autonomie
la seule différence qui reste maintenant
c'est le temps de recharge
le temps de recharge aujourd'hui avec
les chimie moderne de lithium ion en
arriva à 15 minutes à 18 minutes
aujourd'hui de recharge donc ma question
c'est comment on peut justifier des
mobilités à hydrogène pour des buses des
flottes locale je comprends sur la
longue distance mais j'arrive pas à
comprendre comment on peut justifier sur
des bus ou des flottes ou des flottes
locale aujourd'hui hydrogène versus
électricité en 30 % versus rendement de
90 %
notre magasin c'est un rendement de 30 %
mais avec de l'énergie qui est
disponible au moment où elle est
produite à ce produced et non pas au nom
vous avez besoin pour recharger deux et
donc elle n'a pas la même valeur comme
le soulignait jean marc jancovici tout à
l'heure et je dirais que au fond peu
importe sa valeur d'autant plus qu'une
fois que vous avez investissements la
valeur de l'électricité est pratiquement
un coût marginal nul
deuxième point vous avez toute une série
d' usage pour lequel le temps de
recharge est absolument critique le taxi
y travaille et il n'a pas envie d'être
d'être en recharge il a envie de prendre
des clients
troisièmement vous avez des usages
notamment des bus qui fonctionne de 5h
le matin à 1h du matin dans un certain
nombre de villes et quatre heures de
recharge la nuit ça suffit pas pour
refaire le plein des batteries enfin dès
que vous parlez en véhicules lourds je
suis désolé mais le camion tesla qui
commence par transporté 4 tonnes et huit
batteries
ça me paraît pas un optimum du point de
vue économique
ni du point de vue de l'utilisation de
la charge totale du camion donc pour
toutes ces raisons nous pensons que
l'hydrogène un créneau dans la mobilité
et qu' il va continuer à se développer
pour des véhicules qui a une forte
intensité de service et pour lequel le
temps de recharge est critique ans que
je compte ce que je comprends pas je
continue le complément de ma question en
ce moment là c'est pourquoi vouloir
diriger l'hydrogène électrolytique ne
lui soit propre
le seul en fait preuve aujourd'hui vient
d'être lit d'un jour peut-être deux
après de la capture du carbone est
pourquoi le diriger dans les mobilités
alors qu'il ya des quantités colossales
c'est aujourd'hui 98 % voire 99 %
5 % de l'hydrogène qui a utilisé des
applications industrielles
essentiellement ans et qui sont et qui
sont très carbonées aujourd'hui
extrêmement carbonée là on veut faire
les deux on veut faire le veut en aucun
cas on veut se limiter à la mobilité les
premiers grands dirigeants de la
mobilité alors qu'il ya une solution
excellent quand je vous disais la
convention des premiers grands projets
de production d'hydrogène promu par
angie sont pour des usages industriels
de dire que nous avons de mémoire fait
un communiqué de presse sur notre accord
avec anglo american pour faire des
camions à hydrogène pour des mines isolé
en afrique du sud
nous avons deux mémoires publié un
communiqué je sais plus si c'est en
australie occidentale pour la
fabrication d'engrais donc la production
massive d'hydrogène pour faire de
l'ammoniac pour faire des engrais verts
donc mais la mobilité est aussi un usage
de l'hydrogène et on voit aucune raison
pour s'en priver
je suis désolé le temps de recharge de
10 aujourd'hui on a on avait chili on
arrive à les battre la 10e minute un
haut niveau au niveau des cellules on
préfère ça avec les puissances qui sont
nécessaires et georges et un camion un
camion avec une patrick cape town en 18
minutes
il vous faut une centrale nucléaire à
chaque station service on va garder
puissance ne passe pas on recharge
connaissent pas on recherche des ferries
en norvège aujourd'hui de capital water
le temps de charger les voitures ça
tourne en ce moment c'est pas que c'est
pas une histoire
la deuxième chose c'est que les
autonomies aujourd'hui sa voiture on
arrive à 4 500 kilomètres des taxis sont
pas sa faune - et en plus les chinois
ont développé maintenant on en est à 300
stations de changement rapide des
batteries c'est qu'on change une
batterie en deux minutes et ça c'est des
flottes de taxis qui tourne aujourd'hui
en chine en 2010 à dakar on demande à 2
90% et pas de 30% sur sur l'électricité
utilisée est encore une fois de la même
électricité
on parle pas de la vérité dans un cas
vous avez l'électricité pilotable et
vous avez besoin de la puissance au
moment où vous les charger dans les
dix-huit minutes où les charger dans
l'autre cas vous avez de l'électricité
qui était produite quand elle a été
produite à coût marginal nul et que vous
avez stocké sous forme d'hydrogène
l'essentiel de recharge et de nuit
aujourd'hui donc il faut au bon moment
quand il est restée packard venue est
pas si vous n'avez pas si vous avez une
forte intensité de service et que de
l'ordre chargées de la journée dans les
joutes et on a quatre avec 400 à 500 km
d'autonomie aujourd'hui un taxi fait
largement en plus en ville ça fait moins
que c'est encore plus que ça donc ya pas
besoin de l'hydrogène dans ces cas là
écoutez moi je constate qu'à une
clientèle pour les taxis à hydrogène
oui parce que c'est du show du show
politique jeune homme a fait le rapport
des mighty commentaires sur le nucléaire
oh non j'ai pas lu donc j'ai pas de
loranger pas de commentaire une question
sur le captage de co2 par par contre
j'ai un commentaire sur valeur donc
moins que moi dans dix minutes il faut
vraiment j'y aille
d'accord je comprends les questions
populaire il capte une question sous
pour les deux orateurs ce que
pensez-vous du captage de co2 moi je
veux répondre rapidement
sur le papier ça serait une bonne idée
en pratique quand on voit les obstacles
je pense que mes enfants sont mortes que
ça sera toujours pas un truc déployés à
l'orge échelle il ya deux ou trois deux
ou trois obstacles importants dont on
parle bien là dessus du captage sur les
installations de combustion
il ya un captage aujourd'hui il commence
à être fait de manière un peu
significative
c'est la séparation du co2 du gaz en
sortie de gisements de gaz et c'est la
raison pour laquelle les norvégiens sont
devenus très bons en séquestration du
co2 parce que ça c'est un co2 qui se
sait pas ce qui n'est pas en sortie
d'installation combustion donc par
exemple c'est pas polluée par des
poussières solide et c'est quelque chose
que les norvégiens arrive à faire sans
en sortie d'installation de combustion
les procédés qui sont actuellement
utilisées comme le co2 est une molécule
chimiquement inerte c'est un oxyde et
bien pour aller capter une molécule
d'eau chimiquement inerte il faut
dépenser beaucoup d'énergie et en
l'occurrence il faut faire absorber
cette molécule puis il a désormais dans
un bada bing en a besoin pas les
chauffer et ça mange entre 20 et 30% de
l'énergie qui est livrée par
l'installation de combustion donc c'est
à dire en pratique ça fait 20 à 30 %
d'électricité en moins si une centrale
électrique 20 à 30% de ciment au moins 6
et une cimenterie etc
et ce problème là est un problème qui
n'est pas un bruit de coût à la tonne de
co2 évitée c'est un brave de
répercussions à l aval de la production
qu'on va perdre parce qu'on a perdu des
volumes sur la production dans l'unité
qui fait l'objet d'une capture et
séquestration
deuxième problème à résoudre c'est que
les gens sont pas d'accord pour avoir
une autoroute dans le fond de leur
jardin je préfère qu'ils seraient
d'accord pour avoir un gros tuyau de co2
qui a et de l'installation combustion
jusqu'à l'endroit où à l'enfouir puisque
l'installation combustion et pas
nécessairement situé au même endroit le
co2 est un gaz plus lourd que l'air pour
le roux s'il ya une fuite dans le tuyau
les gens qui sont à proximité des tuyaux
on va trouver ça très drôle
il ya eu un cas d' asphyxie célèbre par
ailleurs être naturel de co2 dans ces
lacs africains et les gens qui sont
situés sur la rive sont morts à
l'échelle planétaire c'est pas un risque
majeur et c'est tout pareil comme s'ils
n'arrivent que local c'est comme pour
les déchets nucléaires ça va pas se
mettre
il faut il faut vraiment passer en
économie guerre pour l'imposer dernier
point il faut avoir des couches
géologiques ou d'injecter alors ça on
sait faire
donc tout ça est techniquement faisable
mais le gros prix à payer j'ai envie de
dire du déploiement à large échelle de
cette technologie
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'énergie penalty
et j'ai évoqué au début et qui fait
qu'on se prive d'une partie de la
production approvisionnement fossiles
identique on avait avant la solution
inverse en une centrale à charbon c'est
que puisqu'on à 30% de chaleur en moins
c'est pas grave on va augmenter de
charbon de 40% comme ça on a toujours
une quantité d'électricité et à sedan on
tombe sur d'autres problèmes
quelques logistique du chardon c'est
très compliqué qu'on n'augmente pas les
capacités de 40% comme ça qu'il faut
changer tous les brûleurs parce qu'ils
sont dimensionnés donc tout ça pour dire
que en économie guerre c'est comme pour
le nucléaire pour un certain nombre d'
usage et à condition d'arriver à
répercuter à laval la perte de
production qui s'ensuit ça peut
fonctionner je ne prends pas une seule
seconde qu'on sera au niveau de ce que
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
avait mis dans son scénario 2 degrés il
ya quelques années dans lequel on sait
est très 30 10 milliards de tonnes de
co2 par an scénario 2 2 même en national
de l'énergie
il ya des tonnes de co2 par an
c'est-à-dire plus en masse que le poids
combiné de pétrole et de gaz qui a fait
sortir aujourd'hui les entrailles de la
terre
bon ça diront oui c'est point on dit
pense pas que le ccs soit une solution
massive au problème du changement
climatique en revanche localement pour
un certain nombre de solutions ça peut
marcher en particulier je pense à la
production de ciment où on sort du co2
presque pur je pense à certains procédés
de l'industrie chimique comme on sort du
co2 presque pur et là on peut utiliser
le co2 en recombinaison avec l'hydrogène
pour faire véhicule mais là où ça casse
toi part du non ne séquestre pas on se
contente de boucler la boucle et
maintenant parce que sinon je sera brûlé
derrière donc il faut intégrer le fait
que l'option de vire en substitution
d'un autre fuel fossile qu'on laisse ou
ternes
ça dépend d'où vient le co2 mais s'il
vient de la calcination de la chaux tant
qu'on ne sait pas faire autrement du
ciment cdu c'est ce que je dis c'est que
pour que ce soit un truc qui contribue à
la baisse des émissions planétaires
il faut que le lit fuel qu'on fait avec
ce sirop de la vienne en substitution et
non pas en âge ou de combustibles
fossiles ailleurs pendant la grève juste
ça que ces conditions les buts
supplémentaires
mais voilà donc pour nous ces solutions
de capture de co2 il réutilisation
d'ailleurs plus que de stockage je pense
et y compris à la réutilisation dans le
ciment puisque le cecim on peut capturer
des proportions de co2 non négligeables
c'est un moyen parmi d'autres mais ça ne
sera jamais la solution miracle que en
avait fait la une qui faisait bouclé son
bilan avec st voilà donc on va pas à
priver jean-marc sur le site sur un tour
à vélo deux minutes de conclusions
chacun chez désolé pour les questions
qu'on n'a pas pu poser
on pourra y vendent moins de diffuser la
liste des questions qui ont été posées
vos dernier mot dans quel ordre
bah vous choisissez jean-marc quelques
mots de conclusion je pense alors je
redis ce que j'ai dit en entrée mais
pour en tirer les conclusions
différentes
cette histoire de transition énergétique
fait quand on regarde l'histoire de
l'humanité c'est depuis des millénaires
c'est une histoire de transition
énergétique puisque les hommes et du
divers que se sont créées ne sont rien
d'autre que les convertisseurs d'énergie
encore est un convertisseur d'énergie
le monde dans lequel nous vivons et eu
comme je le disais une organisation
dissipatifs donc utilisé vient donc la
transition énergétique c'est un truc est
aussi vieux que l'humanité
on a transitionner en essayant
domestiques et les animaux domestiques
et l'énergie du feu c'est du coup pas
dissociable cette affaire de transition
énergétique de tous les autres sujets
que nous manipulons si là dessus je vais
finir un des gros problèmes
nous avons aujourd'hui avec les débats
sur la transition c'est qu'on traite les
choses en silo en compte cinq
le débat sur la transition ça se traite
à un autre moment que le débat sur les
retraites où le débat sur les programmes
scolaires où le débat sur la
construction européenne
le débat sur la politique alors en fait
non tous les débats que j'ai insulté
sont des sous ensembles du débat sur la
transition énergétique parce que
l'énergie c'est la capacité ou pas à
maîtriser son environnement avec les
bons et les mauvais effets qui en
découlent donc la conclusion que je
voudrais apporter c'est que il me semble
que si on veut avoir une bonne chance de
faire basculer un peu plus le fléau de
la balance vers la case je gère ce qui
nous a réunis là plutôt que je subis il
est urgent de laisser beaucoup plus d
espace à la compréhension systémique du
monde dans lequel on vit à la formation
de tous les gens qui ont besoin de
prendre des décisions pour qu'un truc
par exemple j'aimerais bien que angie
toutes les autres entreprises face c'est
que tous les carrelages insiste surtout
les cadres se prennent 20 heures de
cours
j'ai et c'est pas de la sensibilisation
ne s'agit pas de leur demander de lire
le journal s'agit de former des ordres
de grandeur les post physique les liens
de cause à conséquence
biencourt pas correctement géré à paris
n'a pas compris et pour le moment ça
reste encore l'essentiel de la
population qui doit prendre des
décisions qui sous une forme ou sous une
autre
s'inscrivent dans ce cas était
l'histoire séculaire des hommes c'est à
dire au fond en transition énergétique
diallo premièrement je crois que nous
sommes très ambitieux comme les jean
marc jancovici c'est à dire nous
considérons que l'objectif c'est bien là
d être neutre en carbone en 2050 et que
toute autre solution et conduit à des
situations inacceptables mais nous nous
sommes une entreprise et nous avons une
approche nécessairement un peu
microéconomiques et finalement le
dialogue avec les clients avec nos
parties prenantes avec les collectivités
locales nous a enseigné la modestie
c'est à dire que nous ne vont pas voter
pas comment interpréter cette affaire
bâtiment chez les clients c'est le
constat qu'on fait c'est que quand on
est quand on passe d'une centrale
nucléaire à une éolienne ya un facteur
1000 en puissance quand on passe aux
panneaux solaires est encore un facteur
1000 ce qui fait que quelque chose qui
était nécessairement une décision
centralisée devient aujourd'hui quelque
chose qui est à la main de la
collectivité locale voire à la main du
client individuel et ça ça veut dire que
la prise de décisions pour que la
transition énergétique se fasse elle ne
se fait pas uniquement discutant avec la
puissance publique elle se fait en
discutant avec la collectivité locale
avec l'industriel avec le client
particulier est la bonne solution
celle qui est acceptable qui dans un
cadre donné
de démocratie de prix du carbone de etc
peut se construire et réduire le co2
elle dépend des ressources qui sont
disponibles localement elle reçut dépend
de ce que le client veut faire des
besoins de la sobriété qu'il est prêt de
l'effort de sobriété qu'il est prêt à
faire et nous on n'a pas de vocation
macroéconomique est ce que la somme de
toutes les actions auxquelles nous
contribuerons réduit lé co2 ça nous
pouvons l'affirmer
est-ce que ça contribuera globalement
assuré plus tôt la croissance la
décroissance
on n'en sait rien et d'ailleurs ce n'est
pas notre rôle par contre on a un
certain nombre de convictions
une conviction première c'est que la
priorité des priorités c'est
l'élimination du charbon une deuxième
conviction qui est que la résilience des
systèmes à toutes les échelles dépend
essentiellement de la diversification
des sources et des solutions qui sont
mises en oeuvre
la troisième c'est que les différents
vecteurs énergétiques l'électricité le
gaz les réseaux de chaleur sont
complémentaires et qui sont plus
efficaces si on essaye de les utiliser
ensemble chacun pour ce à quoi il est le
mieux adapté que si on essaye d'en
utiliser unique un uniquement un pour
rendre tous les services on a la
conviction vous l'avez compris à travers
mes propos que l'hydrogène est promis à
un bel avenir de ce point de vue là on
se réjouit des efforts du plan de
relance mais ce que je voudrais dire
surtout c'est que
au sein des gee on a essayé de faire ce
que disait jean marc jancovici c'est à
dire d'avoir des cadres qui ont étudié
les problèmes de la transition
énergétique qui veulent y contribuer et
ils veulent y contribuer et pas
seulement parce qu'on pense que c'est
bien l'entreprise mais parce que nous
aussi on a des enfants et mes
petits-enfants et que ce qu'on veut à la
fin des fins c'est leur laisser un monde
plus vivable et c'est ce pour quoi on
travaille tous les jours
merci à tous ceux-là de ce débat et de
votre attention
merci ben merci à tous alors vous
recevrez dans quelque temps un compte
rendu de cette discussion
surtout si vous nous laissez vos
coordonnées mail
et voilà je pense que le conte ont bu
remettra les choses on a décidé beaucoup
de choses et je pense que la lecture du
conte ont du reste ce sera tout aussi
passionnant que l'a suivi de ce débat